Welcome everyone to this evening of sitting by the fireplace on the bearskin rug and sitting on whatever beverage you want to use your imagination about and thinking about all the wonderful... Oh, wait, this is 2021. Never mind. No, I'm just kidding. So we got a holiday show. It's, I guess it's a tradition as much as we've been doing this way too many years. It's become ingrained. We have some good questions from users in the discord. And so we'll be, we'll be doing those. Some people are here listening live. So shout out to all the people live listening to this later hearing that they were listening live. And in general, yeah, just going to have a little bit of a casual episode where we uh talk about what's been amazing this year uh that'll be short
大家晚上好，欢迎来到这个炉火旁熊皮地毯上的夜晚，坐在你们想凭想象力享用的任何饮料旁，想着所有美妙的……哦，等等，这是2021年。没关系。不，我开玩笑的。所以我们有一场节日节目。我想，既然我们已经做了这么多年，这差不多成了一个传统。它已经根深蒂固了。我们从Discord的用户那里收到了一些很好的问题。所以我们会，我们会回答这些问题。有些人在这里实时收听。所以向所有以后听到自己是在实时收听的听众们大声打个招呼。总的来说，是的，我们只是要做一个轻松的节目，我们呃谈谈今年有哪些了不起的事呃，这会很短
and uh it's been a tough year man but there's been a lot of good too yeah yeah i actually like i feel bad i mean it's been a really hard year for a lot of people i think we said that last year too which it was last year too uh this year was supposed to be better i went to the party store to pick up some supplies for like christmas which first of all like everything was out of stock that was horrible i noticed that too yeah so so is that related to the you think to the supply chain issue or i wonder what's going on there oh yeah i assume everything gets blamed on covet and supply chain i i'm sure that is true a lot, but I'm not sure to what degree it's true. But I saw all the New Year's stuff was like, you know, screw 2021, 2022 or bust, you know, all this stuff.
嗯，这真是艰难的一年，伙计，但也有很多美好的事，是的，是的，实际上，我觉得很糟糕，我是说，对很多人来说这真是艰难的一年，我想我们去年也这么说过，去年确实也很艰难，呃，今年本来应该更好的，我去派对商店买一些圣诞节的用品，首先，所有的东西都断货了，太糟糕了。我也注意到了，是的，所以，你觉得这和供应链问题有关吗，或者我想知道那里发生了什么，哦，是的，我假设什么都怪到新冠和供应链上，我确信这在很大程度上是真的，但我不确定在多大程度上是真的。但我看到所有新年相关的装饰，你知道，都是“去你的2021，2022破釜沉舟”之类的话，你知道，所有这些。
And I'm just thinking, it's like, I feel like we've been on this roller coaster before. Yeah, so yeah, I totally agree. I think, I feel like 2021 was better than 2020. I mean, obviously like personally, anything could happen, but I feel like for globally, I feel like 2021 was better, but I'm not totally sure.
而我一直在想，这就像，我觉得我们以前坐过这个过山车。是的，所以，是的，我完全同意。我认为，我觉得2021年比2020年要好。我是说，显然，就个人而言，任何事情都可能发生，但我觉得从全球来看，我觉得2021年更好，但我并不完全确定。
I haven't thought about it enough. We also have gifts. We're going to be giving out t-shirts to lucky patrons. I actually took the Excel spreadsheet, did the primitive thing of calling Rand on all the rows and then sorting. I'll salt and pepper some winners' names on the Discord raffle. So thank you all for supporting the show. You know, pretty much all the money goes back into the show, either to cover server costs. We try to get more folks into the show, you know, by advertising and, you know, especially try and look for folks who are, you know,
我没有考虑得足够多。我们还有礼物。我们要把T恤送给幸运的赞助人。我实际上用了Excel电子表格，做了一个原始的事情，对所有行调用随机数（Rand），然后进行排序。我会在Discord抽奖中撒点盐和胡椒粉选出赢家。所以谢谢大家支持这个节目。你知道，几乎所有的钱都回馈给了节目，或者用来支付服务器费用。我们试图通过广告让更多的人了解这个节目，你知道，特别是试着寻找那些，你知道的
just starting their career or high school or college and try and get them interested. And I actually, you know, just starting their career or high school or college and try and get them interested. And I actually, you know, I started a new job, which we could talk about at some point later, but it was kind of cool. A couple of people reached out to me and said, hey, you know, I used to listen to your show. You know, I don't anymore because I'm old. No, I'm just kidding. No, they said, like, I got into programming from listening to your show um you know now I work at you know your company and everything
刚开始职业生涯、或者高中生或大学生，并试着让他们感兴趣。而我实际上，你知道，刚开始职业生涯、或者高中生或大学生，并试着让他们感兴趣。而我实际上，你知道，我找到了一份新工作，我们可以在以后某个时候聊聊，但这挺酷的。有几个人联系我，说，嘿，你知道，我以前听过你的节目。你知道，我不再听了，因为我老了。不，我开玩笑的。不，他们说，我因为听了你的节目而开始接触编程，嗯，你知道，现在我在你的公司工作，诸如此类的
so it was really cool um and so we try and uh you know reach as many folks as possible and you know patrons are a big part of that so I really appreciate that patreon has grown really big like not just ours and thankful to all those people but like i notice it's really like garnered its place in like the internet i think kickstarter was kind of like that thing for a while i don't know i'm not uh hip but i feel like kickstarter might have jumped the shark a bit like but patreon like wow like the number of people i see now like doing patreon subscriptions has like really exploded i think even patreon went or is going to go public and so i mean they've really become a big thing like i was oh i was talking with someone about you know youtubers right because that's always a thing now
所以这真的很酷，嗯，所以我们尽量，你知道，接触尽可能多的人，你知道赞助人（patreon）是其中很大的一部分，所以我真的很感激Patreon已经变得非常大，不仅仅是我们，感谢所有这些人，但我注意到它真的像是在互联网上赢得了自己的一席之地，我认为Kickstarter曾经在一段时间内就是那样，我不知道，我不是很时髦，但我觉得Kickstarter可能有点过气了，但是Patreon，哇，我看到现在做Patreon订阅的人数真的爆炸式增长了。我想甚至Patreon已经或将要上市，所以，我的意思是，他们真的变成了一件大事，就像我，哦，我跟某人谈论过YouTuber对吧，因为那现在总是一个热门话题
like oh this youtuber that youtuber like they got you know how much money they're making all that stuff and uh you know jason and i aren't youtubers but being that we have a podcast i mean i guess we have a bit of knowledge about how that works. And it's like, I know why all those people have Patreons on the side and why they push their merch so hard is because, yeah, I mean, the money to be made from actual viewers is pretty bad. Yep. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. You know, I don't really like I saw a bit more inside baseball since it is the holiday episode. We vet our advertisers very, very carefully. You'll never see us saying,
比如，哦，这个YouTuber，那个YouTuber，他们赚了多少钱，所有这些东西，呃，你知道，杰森和我不是YouTuber，但既然我们有一个播客，我想我们对那是怎么运作的有一点了解。而且就像，我知道为什么所有人都在一旁搞Patreon，以及为什么他们这么卖力地推销他们的周边，因为，是的，我的意思是，从实际观众那里赚到的钱真的很糟糕。是的。是的，完全正确。你知道，我真的不喜欢，我看到更多内幕消息，因为这是节日特辑。我们对广告商的审核非常非常严格。你永远不会看到我们说，
oh, buy gold or here's health insurance. It's always things that we- The best underwear. Yeah, what was the one that everyone was doing? The Dollar Shave Club. Yeah, we're not doing Dollar Shave Club. It's all things that we believe in. But because of that, these are folks that I think they don't have massive, massive multi-billion dollar advertising budgets. So advertising is great. We really appreciate the sponsors of the show, but really Patreon is what we use to really get the word out there. And so I think that's really important. It keeps the show authentic.
哦，买黄金，或者这是健康保险。总是那些我们——最好的内衣。是的，那个每个人都在做的是什么？美元剃须俱乐部（Dollar Shave Club）。是的，我们不做美元剃须俱乐部。这些都是我们相信的东西。但正因为如此，这些是我认为没有庞大无比的数十亿美元广告预算的人。所以广告很棒。我们非常感谢节目的赞助商，但实际上Patreon才是我们用来真正宣传的工具。所以我认为这真的很重要。它保持了节目的真实性。
And so, yeah, I think you'll see more and more of that, of people moving to that model. So let's see if we can do, this is a bit impromptu, but maybe we can start off here. What is something this year from a programming perspective that you think you've changed your mind on, learned, adopted, that you kind of picked up something for like, not just like speculative, maybe we'll do that later, but like, what is something that you this year feel like you took on programming wise? Yeah, that's a really good question.
所以，是的，我想你会看到越来越多这样的人转向这种模式。那么让我们看看我们能不能这样做，这有点即兴，但也许我们可以从这里开始。今年从编程的角度来看，你认为你改变了什么想法、学到了什么、采纳了什么、你偶然拾得了什么，不仅仅是推测性的，也许我们以后会做那个，但是，你今年觉得你在编程方面承担了什么？是的，这是个很好的问题。
Sorry, I should have given it to you in advance. No, no, I think it's fine. This year, it's been a few years since I really got into Visual Studio Code. I mean, that might have been a 2019 thing. But in 2021, one thing I, well, so a couple of things. One thing is I started getting better about taking notes. So I know it's not totally a programming related thing, but I started doing a lot more kind of Google Docs and having a Google Drive that's kind of organized and keeping a lot of notes on different things. That's been really helpful. Anything I can kind of put down
抱歉，我应该提前告诉你。不，不，我觉得没关系。今年，距离我真正开始接触Visual Studio Code已经好几年了。我是说，那可能已经是2019年的事了。但在2021年，有一件事，好吧，所以有几件事。有一件事是我开始更擅长做笔记了。所以我知道这不完全是一个与编程相关的事情，但我开始做很多类似谷歌文档（Google Docs）的事情，并拥有一个井井有条的谷歌云端硬盘（Google Drive），并在不同的事情上保留大量的笔记。这真的很有帮助。任何我能记录下来的东西
on e-paper is one less thing I have to just keep in active memory in my brain. And so I can kind of put it there and then I only have to remember to check it. And so if I put enough things there, it works out. One thing I really got into more is using Tmux. So, you know, I've used Tmux for a while, but now it's just become the sort of de facto thing. Like right when I log into a machine, I'll jump into Tmux. Because otherwise, like you might get going and then you lose internet or your machine goes to sleep because you, you know, especially with working from home, like you might be into something, you know, and then the doorbell rings. And so, and then you end up doing something in the backyard. And then it only takes maybe at least on my laptop, like 10, 15 minutes for the laptop
在电子纸上，就可以少在我的大脑活跃记忆中保留一件事。所以我可以把它放在那里，然后我只需要记住去检查它。所以如果我在那里放足够多的东西，它就会起作用。我真正开始深入使用的是Tmux。所以，你知道，我用Tmux有一段时间了，但现在它已经变成了事实上的标准。就像我登录一台机器时，我就会直接跳进Tmux。因为否则，比如你可能正干着呢，然后断网了，或者你的机器进入睡眠状态，因为你，你知道，特别是远程办公，你可能正专注干着某件事，你知道，然后门铃响了。然后，你最后跑去后院做别的事去了。然后，只需要可能至少在我的笔记本电脑上，花上大约10、15分钟，笔记本电脑
to go to sleep and your SSH connection is busted. I've started using Eternal Terminal and Tmux for almost everything. And even like my Visual Studio Code and my Jupyter Notebook and all of that, I have all of those going through Eternal Terminal tunnels. So none of those connections are ever broken. And so that's kind of a workflow change
就会进入睡眠状态，你的SSH连接就断了。我开始在几乎所有事情上使用Eternal Terminal和Tmux。甚至像我的Visual Studio Code、我的Jupyter Notebook以及所有这些，我都是通过Eternal Terminal隧道运行所有这些的。所以这些连接永远不会断开。所以这是一种工作流程的改变
I've started doing this year. Interesting. I'll give two for myself. So my first one, I need to be better about what you're describing. I guess I do a bit more on local machines. So not kind of SSH-ing around as much. So I guess I get by with not investing in a good solution there.
我今年开始这样做了。有趣。我为自己说两个。所以第一个，我需要在我刚才描述的方面做得更好。我想我在本地机器上做得更多一点。所以不会像那样到处进行SSH连接。所以我想我没有在那里投资一个好的解决方案也能凑合。
Yeah. But I think for me, so from like a programming perspective, I think I took on a bit more sort of like math and statistics kind of stuff, which I've worked with a lot of people who are very deep into statistics, or even I think you're a bit into statistics more than me. But like trying to sort of not shy away from, you know, looking at lots of data and trying to come up with ways of understanding that data without just literally looking at all of it um so that's been one thing that i've tackled um and i still been doing most of that in c++ for my for my day job well yeah like stat stuff what do you use that eigen or something uh i mean most i guess i'm doing it at such a simple level it's just mostly like using building it up from like small level calls of you know the base base stuff like nothing oh is this kind of like a map produce
是的。但我觉得对我来说，从编程的角度来看，我觉得我接触了更多类似数学和统计学的东西，我曾和许多深入研究统计学的人合作过，或者甚至我觉得你比我更懂一点统计学。但就像试着不回避，你知道，查看大量的数据，并试图想出不用字面上去看所有这些数据就能理解这些数据的方法，所以这是我一直在解决的一个问题，而且我仍然在我的日常工作中主要用C++来做这件事。好吧，是的，比如统计类的东西，你用的是Eigen还是什么？我是说，大部分我想我是在一个如此简单的层面上做的，它基本上就像是用小级别的调用构建起来的，比如基础的东西，没有什么，哦，这有点像MapReduce
type thing no just like even like before like someone gives you like you were saying oh i have an excel chart of you know names right and then like oh i generated a random number so you know a question would be like oh how do you know without looking through all of those that you've got all the numbers covered or that the numbers are evenly distributed or whatever, or even what are various distributions? And so those kinds of things and trying to take measures of data, not like big data crunching or statistics on that. Just like literally, for me, that was not something that I had previously kind of tried to tackle head on
那种类型的东西吗？不，甚至就像以前一样，有人给你，就像你说的，哦，我有一个名字的Excel图表，对吧？然后就像，哦，我生成了一个随机数，所以一个问题可能是，哦，你怎么知道在不浏览所有这些的情况下，你已经覆盖了所有的数字，或者这些数字是均匀分布的，或者不管怎样，甚至什么是各种分布？所以诸如此类的事情，并试图对数据进行测量，而不是像大数据处理或那上面的统计。只是字面意思，对我来说，这不是我以前尝试正面解决的事情，
is, you know, I generally got other people to take on the math or analytics of something. That makes sense. That makes sense. Low bar, low bar. And then the second thing is for the first time that I can remember, I'm trying to remember if I ever did it in person. I don think i rarely did it formally as such but i did pair programming what really i've always heard this and i've always been skeptical so i'd love okay so yeah so you've not done it either okay i was probably like the only one so we had some me and a co-worker a
就是，你知道，我通常让别人来承担某事的数学或分析工作。这说得通。这说得通。门槛低，门槛低。然后第二件事是，据我所能记住的，这是第一次，我在努力回想我是否曾经亲自做过。我觉得我很少以这种正式的方式去做，但我进行了结对编程。真的？我一直听到这个，而且我一直持怀疑态度，所以我很乐意，好吧，所以是的，所以你也没做过？好吧，我可能就像是唯一的一个。所以我们有一些，我和一个同事，
co-worker and i sorry would, had a problem to work and some image processing related stuff, which I had done before. Actually, you and I did that. That was the first time you and I doing it was the first time I really tackled it. And so I was like, oh, you know, I have some experience here.
一个同事和我，抱歉，有一个问题要处理，和一些图像处理相关的东西，我以前做过。实际上，你和我做过那个。那是你和我第一次做，是我真正开始解决它的时候。所以我想，哦，你知道，我这里有一些经验。
Let's like, and this was virtual. So we use CLion, which is like IntelliJ by JetBrains. And they had like rolled out a new feature where you could like do pair programming. It's like a, you know JetBrains and they had like rolled out a new feature where you could like do pair programming it's like a you know live google doc but like your code and I think other people have similar tools as well I think even VS Code has an option for doing this and so um we're like oh let's hop on a session we'll get on like a call with each other and then you know we'll just like you know hash this out together and like literally like I'll type in one
让我们像，而且这是虚拟的。所以我们使用CLion，它就像JetBrains的IntelliJ。他们推出了一项新功能，你可以像进行结对编程一样。它就像一个，你知道，JetBrains，他们推出了一项新功能，你可以像进行结对编程一样，它就像一个，你知道的，实时的谷歌文档，但它是你的代码，而且我认为其他人也有类似的工具，我认为甚至VS Code也有一个可以做到这一点的选项，所以，我们就像，哦，让我们加入一个会话，我们互相打个电话，然后，你知道，我们就会像，你知道，一起把这个琢磨出来，字面意思就是，我输入一个
function you're typing in the function below me. And like, we're doing before it like never made sense to me, because like, you have only one keyboard. And I guess I probably was thinking about it wrong. But like, it never made sense that like, two of us would sit there and like work together, but only one person could type. But in this way, he could, you know, scroll up and check what I was writing, I could scroll down and what he was writing, we would like tweak a function together. And we didn't like go all in on it. But it was like this remembering for me, oddly, is like, this is the first time I ever remember doing like peer programming, like actually sitting here working on literally the same piece of code at the same time.
函数，你在我下面输入函数。而且就像，我们在做之前它对我来说从来没有意义，因为，你知道，你只有一个键盘。我想我可能想错了。但是，像这样，我们两个坐在一起工作，但只有一个人可以打字，这在以前是说不通的。但通过这种方式，他可以，你知道，向上滚动并检查我写的东西，我可以向下滚动看他写的东西，我们可以一起调整一个函数。而且我们没有全盘投入。但对我来说，这是一种奇怪的记忆，就像，这是我记忆中第一次做结对编程，就像实际上坐在那里，同时在字面上的同一段代码上工作。
That sounds awesome. So yeah, when I heard pair programming and maybe I misunderstood it or maybe you've done something slightly different and more advanced, but I always interpret it as, you know, one person's typing, the other person's looking over their shoulder and then they switch.
听起来太棒了。所以，是的，当我听到结对编程时，也许我误解了它，或者也许你做了一些稍微不同和更高级的事情，但我总是把它解释为，你知道，一个人在打字，另一个人在看他们的肩膀，然后他们换班。
And that never quite made sense to me. What you're saying sounds awesome or basically it's, you're both, you know, at your own desks coding but you're coding on the same project at the same time. Yeah, like in the same file. Like in the same source file. Yeah. That is super cool.
这对我来说从来没有真正意义。你刚才说听起来棒极了，或者基本上是，你们俩都在自己的办公桌前写代码，但你们同时在同一个项目上写代码。是的，就像在同一个文件里。就像在同一个源文件里。是的，这太酷了。
How does that work? I mean, it must use like NFS or something. I mean, how do you both edit the same file at the same time? I don't know. I don't know. But then I was thinking, I wonder how many people... So it's like that test-driven development, agile programming pair programming, like you can name off a whole bunch of paradigms, statements or whatever that I know of, I've read about been around a long time, and I'm not sure I ever did it properly. Like I've never attempted to do like I kind of some
那是怎么运作的？我的意思是，它一定使用了像NFS之类 的东西。我的意思是，你们俩怎么能同时编辑同一个文件？我不知道。我不知道。但后来我在想，我在想有多少人……所以就像那种测试驱动开发、敏捷编程、结对编程，你可以说出一大堆我所知道的范式、陈述或无论什么，我读过并在那里存在了很长时间，而且我不确定我是否真的正确地做过它。就像我从未尝试过去做，我有点像其中的一部分或从中学习，但从未坐下来真正做过。这就是其中之一。所以我今年做了，我还会再做的。酷。听起来太棒了。我不认为我一直都在这样做。有些人提倡这应该是你经常做的事情。我不知道是不是这样，但我绝对能看出在某些情况下它真的很有用。是的。所以实际上，现在，你知道，我有更多的时间来思考它。你知道，我最近真正投入的一件事是Next.js。我们采访了来自Next.js的吉列尔莫（Guillermo）。
part of it or learn from but never sat down and actually did it. And this was one of them. So I did it this year, I would do it again. Cool. That sounds amazing. I don't think I do it all the time. Some people advocate that like it's something you would do often. I don't know about that, but like I could definitely see certain situations it being really useful. Yeah. So I actually, now that, you know, I've had more time to think about it. You know, one thing that I've really jumped on recently is Next.js. We interviewed Guillermo from Next.js.
那一定是一年多前的事了。当时我对Next.js一无所知。我的意思是，我对React.js或任何这些东西几乎一无所知。但我想构建一个……实际上，你可以去看看。它处于非常非常alpha的阶段。但我想构建一个类似于谷歌相册的东西，但是要把你自己的照片托管在你自己的云存储上，支付你自己的存储费用。并且你的照片在某种意义上是完全安全的，比如，你知道，没有人能封禁你。你不会丢失你的照片。就像即使这个应用程序，即使这个应用程序倒闭了或者我被公共汽车撞了什么的，你仍然会拥有
It's got to be over a year ago. And at that time, I knew nothing about Next.js. I mean, I knew almost nothing about React.js or any of that. But I wanted to build a... And actually, you can check this out. It's in a very, very alpha stage. But I wanted to build like a Google Photos, but where would be hosting your own photos on your own cloud storage, paying your own storage fees. And your photos are totally safe in the sense of like, you know, like no one could ban you. You can't lose your photos. Like even if the app, even if the app went out of business or I got hit by a bus or something, you'd still have
你所有的照片。所以我构建了一个，它以托马斯·阿奎那（Thomas Aquinas）的名字命名为Aquinas Photos，你可以去Aquinas.photos，或者可能是Aquinas.photo。我不记得了。我想是带S的Aquinas.photos，不管怎样。我用Next.js构建了整个东西，它实际上太棒了。我是说，我是个超级大粉丝。当我刚开始的时候，这是非常令人沮丧的，因为我在网络编程方面有一堆糟糕的设计模式。所以这些，Next.js是非常有主见的。所以当你试图做一些事后看来并不是好的设计的事情时，它就是不让你做，比如根本没有真正的方法可以做到这一点。所以你有点不得不遵循他们的设计，但当我完成后，我回过头来看，我想，哦，哇，这真的是太棒了
all your photos. And so I built, it's called Aquinas Photos after Thomas Aquinas, and you can go to Aquinas.photos, or maybe it's Aquinas.photo. I don't remember. I think it's Aquinas.photos with an S, but anyway. And I built the whole thing in Next.js and it's actually amazing. I mean, I'm a really big fan. When I first started, it was very frustrating because I had a bunch of bad design patterns with respect to web programming. And so these, Next.js is very opinionated. And so when you try to do things that in hindsight are not good design, it just won't let you, like there's just no real way to do it. And so you kind of have to follow their their design but when i was done i kind of looked back and i thought oh wow this is like really nice
而且非常值得投入生产，它可以扩展，而且它就像真的很坚固，嗯，所以是的，我是个超级大粉丝。我的意思是，我认为对于未来的网页开发，我会坚持使用Next.js，它太棒了。好吧，也许让我们，呃，跳进来，回答一个听众的问题，我仍然不知道为什么我用这么高的音调说那句话，因为我当时认为它比实际情况更模棱两可，不管怎样，所以第一个问题是，我甚至不知道你怎么念那个。凯文。哦，是的，我们去了。好吧。对不起。好吧。澄清一下，这个人有一个用户名，但随后他们写了他们的真名。所以我们就用第二个吧。谢谢。在你的职业生涯中，推动你学到最多东西的最大动力是什么？我可能应该在做即兴发挥之前读一下那个
and and very production worthy and it can scale and it it's like really solid um so yeah i'm a really big fan i mean i think for future web stuff i'm gonna stick with next.js it's been awesome all right well maybe let's uh jump in and take a a listener question uh that i still don't know why i said that with like a high pitch because i was thinking it was more ambiguous than it was uh anyways so the first one is by i'm not even know how you say that. Kevin. Oh yeah, there we go. Fair enough. Okay. Sorry. Okay. Just to clear, the person has a username, but then they put their real name. And so we'll just go with the second one. Thank you. What's been the biggest thing that pushed you to learn more during your career? I should have probably read that before we did our impromptu
是找一份新工作并搬到一个地方在业余时间做事情，还是某种新爱好或其他什么东西，然后也是我们一会儿要做的事。是的，继续。我只是想说这是全方位的，所以你的问题仍然很不一样。那倒是，好吧，我来试一下，因为我手头正好有答案，所以我要说的是，对于那些没有听过或听完全部年份的人来说，杰森和我一开始是通过在一家老牌、非常大的公司一起工作而认识的，但不是一家以程序员为主的公司，而且，我会说，我在那里做的编程就像在我的舒适区里。就像我从来没有真正感到被过度推着走。就像我学到了东西，但我从来没有，像我环顾四周，这听起来可能很糟糕，
one. Was it taking a new job and moving moving somewhere doing stuff in your spare time or something like a new hobby or anything else um and then also something we'll do in a second yep go ahead i was just gonna say this is over all time so your question is still pretty different that's true all right i'll take a shot because i actually have a answer at hand for this so i will say that um for those of you who haven't heard or listened to all the years so jason and i like started out meeting each other by working together at a kind of old school very large company but not a programmer first company and um i would say like the programming i did there was like in my comfort zone. Like I never really felt super pushed. Like I learned stuff, but I never, like I looked around, this is going to sound bad,
但就像我环顾四周，我觉得，甚至刚走出大学的时候，我想后来的感觉可能是对的，就像我可能和其他很多在那里的人一样懂编程，甚至比大多数人都要好，对吧？好吧，你，你有点像计算机科学（CS）王朝，我是说你爸爸，当然是，那是，是我爸爸和我的爷爷都是程序员，哦，还有你爷爷，是的，你就像编程界的肯尼迪家族，哦，天哪，也许更好的例子，但你就像，你就像另一个王朝，那不是，让我们换个话题。所以不管怎样，我出现了，就像，你知道，这个，就像那里的编程，我学到了很多，比如个人成长和人际交往。即使在今天，我认为我也从那次经历中学到了很多。
but like I looked around and like, I felt like even coming out of college and I think later probably was correct. Like I probably knew how to program as well as a lot of people that were there or maybe even better than most, right? Well, you're, you're kind of like a cs dynasty right i mean your dad uh sure it was uh was that my dad and my grandfather were both programmers oh and your grandfather yeah you're like the kennedys of programming oh gosh maybe a better example but you're like you're like the what's another dynasty isn't that let's move on to a different topic. So anyways, so I showed up and like, you know, this, like the programming there, like I learned a lot, like personal growth and like interpersonal communication. Even to this day, I think I've learned a lot from that experience.
但从编程的角度来看，我觉得，我并不觉得它真的促使我拼尽全力。就像我可以很轻松地混过去，然后我实际上，我猜像这个故事，杰森最终在硅谷找到了一份工作，他说，帕特里克，老兄，我要搬家了，你绝对应该去面试，来面试吧，我不知道你是不是这么说的，但我们当时在同一个项目上工作。是的，是的，是的，好吧，这倒也是，然后，你知道，杰森叫我来，我。因为就像，你知道，杰森比我编程好得多。那时的面试，我很不适应硅谷风格的面试，杰森能轻松拿下，这不是他的评价。这是我的。所以对大多数人来说，它们非常令人生畏，包括我。所以他帮了我。我不知道你还记不记得这个。就像你收拾行李准备离开时，我去了你家，你帮我辅导如何解决编程问题。不会吧，真的吗？这是一个美妙的记忆，我不记得了。是的，是的，我
But from a programming standpoint, like I, like, I don't feel like it really pushed me to like really try my hardest. Like I could coast a lot um then i actually i guess like the story jason ended up getting a job in silicon valley he's like patrick dude i'm gonna move like you definitely should interview come interview like i don't know if you said this but we were working together on the same project yes yes yes yeah okay fair enough and then so i you know jason told me like you to come i you. Because like, you know, Jason's much better programmer than me. interview at that time, like I was not comfortable doing the Silicon Valley style interview, Jason crushes them, which is not his comment. That's mine. And so they're very intimidating for most people, including me. So he helped me. I don't know if you remember this. Like when you were were packing up to leave i came to your house and you helped coach me through like solving programming problems no way really yeah that's a fantastic memory i don't remember that yeah yeah yeah i
可以更详细地说明，但这会透露一点个人隐私，我稍后再告诉你，但，但是的，所以我们还是去了，所以我得到了杰森去过的同一家公司的职位，可能是因为他在硅谷为我说过好话。当我到那里时，我在溺水。就像我应付不来一样。那些人全都知道自己在做什么。就像我环顾四周，没看到任何人让我觉得，我比那个人强。就像我，你知道，那种冒名顶替综合症完全发作了。而且，这很难。回想起来，如果我知道会这么难，我不敢确定我会不会做。但是搬到硅谷，而且我不认为一定非得是硅谷，尤其是现在，就像，10年前。
could go more into detail but it would reveal a bit of personal details i'll tell you later um but but yeah so so we went there anyway so i got a job at the same company jason had gone to probably because he's had a good word for me in Silicon Valley. And when I showed up there, I was drowning. Like it was like I was in over my head. Those people all knew what they were doing. Like I didn't look around and look at anyone that was like, I'm better than that person. Like I was, you know, that whole imposter syndrome just completely kicked in. And, you know, it was hard. Like looking back, if I knew that was going to be that hard, I'm not sure I would have done it. But moving to Silicon Valley, and I don't think it has to be Silicon Valley, especially not now, like it was, you know, 10 years ago.
但我认为，搬到硅谷，进入那种文化，处于金字塔的最底层，可以说是梯子的底层。而且真的必须全力投入分布式计算和MapReduce。好吧，我想你刚刚切中要害了，因为你之所以会觉得如此具有挑战性，是因为你正在改变学科，而许多其他人，你知道，他们的学位就是分布式计算。是的，我想这全都有关系，对吧？就像，我认为有人在没有背景的情况下给了我一个机会。但我认为无论他们在做什么，人们的水平都是，我以前没有逼过自己。我状态不好。对，然后我加入了运动俱乐部，这些家伙，当然，也许他们是网球明星，我以前从没打过网球，但即使他们打过篮球，也会比我好。所以这真的逼着我学习各种技术。最后，你知道，我的肺活量上去了，我的有氧运动没那么糟了，我能够跟上了，而且，你知道，但那真的逼了我一把，我想说。所以真的全力以赴地接受一份我知道会非常具有挑战性的工作，而不是仅仅找一份我认为自己能做到最好的工作。那真是，太棒了。我的意思是，这是一个伟大的故事，也是非常好的建议。我想，是的，我只回答这个问题。但在我这么做之前，我想在这个问题上加倍强调。你永远应该为你想要的工作去面试。你知道，我今天和一个人谈过，
But I think like moving to Silicon Valley, getting in that culture and being like at the bottom of the stack, like bottom of the ladder, let's say. And like really having to go all in on like distributed computing and map reduces. Well, I think you just hit the nail on the head there because the reason why you, I think, found it so challenging was that you were changing disciplines versus a lot of those people, you know, they got their degree in distributed computing. Yeah, I think it was a bit of all of it, right? Like, I think someone took a chance on me without a background. But I think the caliber of people, no matter what they were doing, were like, I hadn't been pushing myself. I was out of shape. Right. And then I joined, I joined the athletic club and like these people, like, sure, maybe they were tennis stars and I never played tennis
他们一直在等待晋升，以便他们可以去面试另一份工作。我说，好吧，你为什么不直接去面试那份工作呢？你知道，就像在你想达到的任何级别，你知道，通过你的晋升，或者，你知道，我的意思是什么。而且，你知道，如果他们喜欢，就像在你想达到的任何级别，通过你的晋升，或者，你知道，我的意思是什么，并且，你知道，如果他们不给你，那也没关系。但至少你，你应该尝试——去面试你现在想要的工作。而且，是的。听起来，你知道，你，你算是做到了，然后
before, but even if they had played basketball, they would have been better than me. And so like that really pushed me to like learn all sorts of technology. And eventually, you know, I got my lung capacity up and I, uh, my cardio wasn't so bad and I was able to keep up and like, you know, but that really pushed me, I would say. So really going in on like taking a job that I knew would be really challenging rather than just finding a job where I thought I could be the best. That is, yeah, that's fantastic. I mean, it's a great story and also really good advice. I think, yeah, I just I'll answer the question. But before I do that, I want to double down on that. You should always interview for the job you want. You know, I was talking to somebody today
你能够进去并鞭策自己。所以现在你，你完全占了上风。不，不，但我的意思是，看，我看到过，我觉得我的成长比我留在杰森和我最初待的那个地方要大得多。是的，这说得通。你呢？好吧，其实，说实话，
who they were waiting to get promoted so that they could interview for another job. And I said, well, why don't you just interview for that job? You know, like at whatever level you want to be, you know, with your promotion or, you know, where I'm going with this. And just, you know, if they like, like at whatever level you want to be, you know, with your promotion or, you know, or where I'm going with this and, and just, you know, if they don't give it to you, then that's fine. But at least you, you should try like interview for the job you want now. And, um, yeah. And it's, it's, it sounds like, you know, you, you kind of did that and then
我只是想深入探讨一下。你说过，如果让你重来一次，你不会这么做，为什么？是因为它太难了，以至于给你带来了压力，还是——不，不，不，我不是说我不会这么做，我是说，我想如果我知道会有多难——就像我会有多应付不来——我想，我不知道，我想那不太公平，所以，我愿意认为我会再做一次。我的意思是，事后看来这是一个很好的选择，但我认为我没有意识到自己知道得这么少。我们在工作时开玩笑说关于C++的事，就像你经历了那个曲线，
you were able to get in and push yourself. And so now you, uh, you totally dominate. No, no. But I mean, look, I've seen like, I think my growth has been a lot bigger than it would have been if, you know, I had just dated that spot Jason and I were originally. Yeah, that makes sense. What about you? Well, actually, real quick,
你不懂C++，觉得这门语言很诡异，然后你达到了你第一次写继承和模板的水平，然后你就像，我简直是个C++专家，人们说这很难，而且就像我面试这些人，我问他们，你知道，我其实不在乎他们回答什么，我只在乎作为讨论点，但你在一到五的评分标准中会如何评价你的C++技能？任何说四或五的人，我立刻就知道，哦，是的，你才刚上曲线不久，对，因为这就是那种事情之一，他们不知道自己不知道多少，对吧，所以我想这是我没有意识到世界有多大，我们从一个不是以程序员为主的公司，到了一个程序员是公司巨星的硅谷公司。所以你的预期产出和人才水平，以及相应的回报，要高得多得多。是的，这说得通。是的，我的意思是，如果你事先知道你要面对的是什么，那将是压倒性的。如果我去了，花了大约一周的时间去做一份试用工作或别的什么，试用面试，人们总是拿这个开玩笑。我当时可能就会退缩，然后想，哦，我绝对是胜任不了的。但因为
I just want to double click on something. You said that if you had to do it over again, you wouldn't. And why? Is it because it was so difficult that it kind of put a strain on you or no no no i'm not saying i wouldn't do it i'm saying like i think if i would have known how like just how much like under over my head i would be like i guess like i don't know that's i guess that's not a fair so i i like to think i would do it again i mean i feel in hindsight it was a great choice um but i think i didn't realize just how little i knew we make this joke about uh at work we do it about c++ is like you go through that that curve where like
我做出了承诺，因为我搬家了，因为我已经接受了这份工作，所以没有退路。是的，这说得通。是的，这真的很鼓舞人心，伙计。是的，推动我学习更多的最大事情。我的意思是，我想帕特里克所说的话也深深引起了我的共鸣。我的意思是，是的，当我搬到硅谷，搬到一个研究实验室，在那里我遇到了成群的人，他们懂一大堆我几乎没听说过的其他学科，这绝对推动了我真正深入钻研并做了大量的学习。我参加了，你知道，一堆这样的在线课程，或者我观看了来自世界各地大学的视频。以色列有这样一所大学，它在网上有一些免费的优质课程。还有，麻省理工学院的课程。
you don't know c++ like this language is weird then like you get to the level where you first wrote like inheritance and maybe a template and you're like i am a freaking c++ expert people saying this is hard and it's like i interview these people i ask them you know kind of i don't actually care what they answer i just care like as a discussion point but like how would you rate your c++ skills on like a scale of one to five anyone who says four or five i instantly know it's like oh yeah you're really early on the curve um yeah because it's just like one of those things like they don't know how much they don't know like yeah and so i think it was i didn't realize how much bigger
还有一所大学。哦，我不记得是哪一所了，它有一个棒极了的统计学课程，你可以直接去听，你知道，观看所有的课程，它们的制作水平真的很高。但我认为，你知道，除了，呃，仅仅是，你知道，接受一份极具挑战性的工作，我会说推动我学习更多的最大事情是，是的，我觉得只是，你知道，下一些真正很大的赌注。你知道，我认为，比如说，强化学习是一项人们在工业界并不真正使用的技术。所以我决定把它作为一个项目来承担，并弄清楚，好吧，为什么这在现实世界中不起作用？它只在游戏上起作用，并且，并且致力于此，并把我们置于一个位置。我想也许我们俩在这里的故事都是一样的，那就是把自己置于，
the world was and we were going from a company where it was not programmers first just silicon valley company where programmers were like the superstars of the company. And so your expected output and the level of talent and also accordingly, the rewards were much, much higher. Yeah. That makes sense. Yeah. I mean, I think it would have been overwhelming if you had realized what you were in for beforehand. If I had gone and like, yeah, spent like a week there with like a trial job or whatever, a trial interview, people always joke about that. I probably would have come out then like, oh, there's no way I'm going to cut it. But because
你真的在鞭策自己且风险是真实存在的境地中。所以你必须把自己置于这些真正艰难的环境中。而且，你知道，你并不总能成功，但你必须把自己置于那些环境中。就像我以前搞砸过面试。我以前失败过项目。我以前得过差评。你知道，那是因为，你知道，我在冒风险，它们并不总是能成功。如果，如果，如果你总是赢，那就不叫风险。对吧。
I was committed, because I moved, because I already accepted the job, like there was no way out. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, that was really inspiring, man. Yeah, biggest thing that pushed me to learn more. I mean, I guess what Patrick said really resonates with me too. I mean, yeah, when I moved to the Valley and I moved to like this research lab where I met a whole bunch of people who knew a whole bunch of other disciplines that I'd barely heard of, that definitely pushed me to really dive deep and do a lot of learning. I took, you know, a bunch of these online courses, or I watched videos from universities all over the world. There was this university in Israel that had some good courses online for free. There was, um, there was the MIT courses.
所以，是的，承担那些巨大的风险。然后当你处于那种情况下时，真正鞭策自己，不要放弃，你知道，在某个时刻，就像，你知道，你可能会失败，但在那之前，你知道，对自己狠一点。你知道，我认为这是一些很好的建议，可以帮助人们，特别是当他们刚开始的时候。你知道，有些事情现在，你知道，只是，你知道，我甚至不用去想它们。但在当时，你知道，我甚至都不理解。
There was also a university. Oh, I can't remember which one that had an amazing stats class that you could just listen, you know, watch all the courses and they had really good production value. But I think, you know, beyond, uh, just, you know, taking a really challenging job and I would say the biggest thing that pushed me to learn more was, yeah, just I guess taking just really kind of big bets. You know, I think that, you know, there was like, for example, reinforcement learning was this technology that people weren't really using in industry. And so I just decided to take that on as a project and figure out, okay, why does this not work in the real world? It only works on games and, and kind of committed to that and, and put us in a position. I think maybe the story around both, both from both of us here is the same, which is to put yourself in, in positions where
所以我想，你知道，有些事情几乎就像黑魔法一样。我完全不知道它们是怎么运作的。然后到了我能够使用它们的程度。我仍然不知道它们是怎么运作的，但我可以使用它们来应付过去。然后你理解了它们，接着它们就变成了你日常生活的一部分，以至于你甚至没有意识到自己在做这件事。而且你正在一点一点地搭建脚手架，一个接着一个。所以，是的，逼自己一把会真正加速这个过程，因为这需要，
you're really pushing yourself and the risks are real. And so you have to, to put yourself in positions where you're really pushing yourself and the risks are real. And so you have to put yourself in these really tough environments. And, you know, you don't always succeed, but you have to kind of put yourself in those environments. Like I've bombed interviews before. I've failed projects before. I've gotten bad ratings before. You know, that's because, you know, I'm taking risks and they're not always going to succeed. It's not, it's not a risk if, if, if you always win. Right.
这需要你的一生，你知道，去继续下去。所以。是的。你说的这件事，我想我早期并不知道。就像现在，你说的，我想我，我意识到了，并且我试图将它铭刻在心，但是这，你必须让自己处于不舒服且可能失败的境地。就像如果你，如果你没有足够接近失败的边缘，那么你可能就没有在成长。是的。没错。是的。我的意思是，我给你们举一个非常具体的例子。
So, so yeah, take those big risks. And then when you're in that situation, really push yourself and don't give up, you know, at some point, like, you know, you might fail, but until then, you know, push yourself really hard. You know, I think that's some good advice that will help folks out, especially when they're getting started. You know, there are things that now, you know, push yourself really hard. You know, I think that's some good advice that will help folks out, especially when they're getting started. You know, there are things that now, you know, are just kind of, you know, I don't even really think about. But at the time, you know, I didn't even like understand.
嗯，我，我，你知道，我买过，我很久以前买过一套房子，但那是一栋很小的房子。我的父母离得很近。所以他们实际上在，你知道，与房子相关的事情上帮了我很多忙。而且我在上大学，全职工作。所以我真的没有很多时间。所以我真的不认为那是一个真正的房主。那是，那是作弊。但我买了一栋，你知道，大约两年前买了一栋房子。从那以后，我自己做了大量的事情。嗯，你知道，我建了很多东西。我建了墙。嗯，你知道，我建了一个栅栏。嗯，你知道，我做了大量的事情，我建了一条小路，你知道，我铺了花岗岩，我做了各种各样的事情，所有这些都只是通过试着在互联网上查找东西来完成的。而且有些事情我
So I guess, you know, there are things that were kind of almost like black magic. Like I have no idea how they worked. And then it got to the point where I could kind of use them. I still didn't really know how they worked, but I could use them enough to get by. And then you understand them and then they just become just part of your routine to where you don't even realize you're doing it. And you're kind of building this scaffold upon scaffold upon scaffold. And so, so yeah, pushing yourself will really help accelerate that process because it's going
搞砸了。就像我给你举个例子。嗯，我拆了泳池阀门，然后我装不回去了。我其实把它装回去了，但它漏水了，而且我没法让它停止漏水。所以我们不得不叫一个泳池专业人士来，他们真正把它修好了。而且花费，而且实际上，你知道，如果我没那样做，那大概是一个5美元的修理费。但因为我做了那个，花了800美元来修理。而且，你知道，这太糟了，对吧？但那是我愿意承担的风险，因为我，你知道，我正试图鞭策自己，尽可能多地了解房屋所有权。所以我一直在房子里面和外面做一大批其他的事情，比如更换马桶，你知道，更换
to take, it's going to take your whole life, you know, to, to continue on that. So. Yeah. This thing you said, I think I didn't know early on. And like now, like you said, I think I, I realize it and I've tried to ingrain it, but this like, you have to set yourself up to be uncomfortable and potentially fail. Like if you're, if you're not close enough to the edge to fail, then you're probably not growing. Yep. Yep. That's right. Yeah. I mean, I'll give you guys a really concrete example.
要花，这需要你的一生，你知道的，去，去在这条路上继续走下去。所以。是的。你刚才说的那件事，我想我早期并不知道。就像现在，如你所说，我想我，我意识到了这一点，并试图把它刻在脑子里，但这就像，你必须让自己处于不舒服和可能失败的境地。如果你没有足够接近失败的边缘，那么你可能就没有在成长。是的。是的。没错。是的。我的意思是，我给你们举一个非常具体的例子。
Um, I've, I, you know, I bought, I owned a house a long time ago, but it was a very small house. And my parents were really close. And so they actually helped me a lot with, you know, house related things. And I was in college and working full time. So I don't really have a lot of time. So I don't really count that as being a true homeowner. That was, that was cheating. But I bought, you know, a house, you know, about two years ago. And since then I've done a ton of stuff myself. Um, you know, I built a ton of stuff. I've built walls. Um, you know, I've built a fence. Um, you know, I did a ton of, I built a path, you know, I laid down granite, I did all sorts of stuff, all just from trying to look things up on the internet. And there were some things that I
嗯，我，你知道的，我买过，我很久以前曾拥有一栋房子，但那是一栋很小的房子。而且我父母离得很近，所以他们在房屋相关的事情上确实帮了我很多。当时我还在上大学，而且全职工作。所以我其实没有太多时间。因此我并不认为那是一个真正的房主经历。那简直是，那简直是在作弊。但我在大约两年前买了一栋房子，从那以后我亲自动手做了大量的事情。嗯，你知道的，我建造了大量的东西。我砌过墙，嗯，你知道的，我建过栅栏，嗯，你知道的，我做了很多，我铺过小路，你知道的，我铺过花岗岩，我做了各种各样的事情，全都是靠在网上查资料。而且有些事情我
messed up. Like I gave you an example. Um, I took apart the pool valve, and I couldn't put it back together. And I actually put it back together, but it leaked, and I couldn't get it to stop leaking. So we had to call a pool professional to come, and they fixed it for real. And it cost, and actually, you know, if I hadn't done that, it would have been like a $5 fix. But because I did that, it cost $800 to fix. And, you know, that sucked, right? But that was a risk I was willing to take because I, you know, I'm trying to push myself and learn as much as I can about home ownership. And so I've done a whole bunch of other things inside and outside the house, like replace toilets, you know, replaced
搞砸了。就像我给你们举的例子，我拆开了泳池阀门，然后就装不回去了。其实我把它重新装上了，但它漏水了，而且我怎么也止不住漏水。所以我们不得不叫来泳池专业人员，他们真正把它修好了。而且花费，实际上，你知道的，如果我当初没那么做，那本来大概只需5美元就能修好。但因为我做了那件事，修理费花了800美元。你知道的，这太糟糕了，对吧？但这风险是我愿意承担的，因为我，你知道的，我正在努力逼自己一把，尽可能多地学习关于房屋所有权的知识。因此我在房子的里里外外还做了许多其他事情，比如更换马桶，你知道的，更换了
outlets, did a whole bunch of, replaced a bunch of the sprinklers and rerouted sprinklers. And like, I learned a lot more and ultimately saved a lot more than, you know, the $800 I had to eat on that, on that pool valve. Right. And so that's really what it's about is, you know, when you take a long-term view, a lot of these risks make sense. I mean, there's, there's folks on, you know, my team who say, what if I do this project and it doesn't work? Well, I still get a good rating. And, and the answers will, you probably will get, you know, an okay rating if it doesn't work. But, you know, taking these risks over a long
插座，还换了一大堆喷头，并重新铺设了喷头管道。而且，我学到了更多，最终省下的钱远远不止我为了那个泳池阀门自掏腰包的那800美元。没错。所以这才是关键所在，当你从长远来看，许多这样的风险都是合乎情理的。我是说，我团队里有些人会问，如果我做了这个项目却行不通怎么办？好吧，我还是能得到一个不错的评分。而答案通常是，如果行不通，你大概也能得到一个及格的评分。但是，只要你足够努力，从长远
enough period of time will eventually work out if you're working hard. I mean, that sense is a little bit similar to the advice you get with the stock market or something like that. Oh, that's a separate topic. Okay. Yeah, okay. Maybe that's not a segue. That's too much surface area. But yeah, take those risks, push yourself hard. And a single risk could easily pass or fail. And don't let that discourage you if it doesn't work out. Yeah. I mean, yeah, it's an iterative thing, not a single one shot measurement. Yeah, I know. Real quick, we'll do the second part and
的时间跨度来看，冒这些险最终总会得到回报的。我的意思是，这种感觉有点类似于你在股市或其他地方听到的建议。哦，那是另一个话题了。好吧。好吧，也许这并不适合过渡。涉及面太广了。不过，是的，去冒那些险吧，狠狠地逼自己一把。单一的风险很可能会成功，也可能会失败。如果失败了，也不要灰心丧气。对，我的意思是，这是一个迭代的过程，而不是一次性的孤立测量。好吧，我知道了。我们快点进入第二部分，
then we'll jump on to the next question. Favorite city to live in or visit? I venice um you know my my my dad is uh from there originally and i love going back there i mean it's a lot of fun and san antonio which is close to where i live now is actually similar where they have a river walk and they have a it's not quite a gondola ride but it's it's you know there's there's a lot of water around and so i think that kind of aesthetic is really beautiful okay well mine sucks compared to that but But so like living, yeah, we'll try to do each of these faster because we're a bit introspective here at the end of the year. But I mean, as far as living, I've only ever lived in Florida and the Bay Area. So I don't, I've not moved around that much.
然后跳到下一个问题。最喜欢居住或访问的城市是哪个？威尼斯，嗯，你知道的，我爸爸原本是那里人，我特别喜欢回那里去，我是说，那里真的很有意思。圣安东尼奥离我现在的住处不远，其实也差不多，那里也有河滨步道，虽然不完全是坐贡多拉游船，但周围有很多水景，所以我觉得那种美学真的很棒。好吧，我的家乡跟那个没法比，不过既然说到居住，好吧，我们尽量把每个问题都回答快一点，因为我们在年终时都有点内省。不过，就居住而言，我只在佛罗里达州和湾区住过。所以我不，我没有搬过很多次家。
I don't know that I can say too much about places to live. But as far as visiting um interestingly for whatever reason like visiting new york city is just like fascinating to me because it's so different than i think like what i normally do and you can go and you don't have to drive which now i don't drive that much anyways but you just like take the subway everywhere walk and i guess specifically like manhattan and there's just like culture with the museums and broadway shows and then they're shopping there's like things to do outside so like we go and we walk so much like we get tons more like steps on our phone recorded as like how far we we traveled so actually for like at least for me and my family like visiting
我不知道自己对适合居住的地方能发表多少看法。但就旅游而言，嗯，有趣的是，不管出于什么原因，去纽约市旅游对我来说简直太迷人了，因为它和我平时的生活大不相同，你可以去那里，而且不需要开车（虽然现在我本来也不怎么开车），你只要坐地铁去任何地方，步行就行了，我想特别是曼哈顿，那里有博物馆和百老汇演出带来的文化气息，还有购物，有户外活动可以做，所以我们去那里会走很多路，手机上记录的步数会暴增，记录着我们走了多远。所以实际上，至少对我个人和我的家庭来说，去
like manhattan is great every time we go i was like maybe maybe we like move here but i think moving and visiting are two very different uh ways of experiencing a city yeah yeah totally yeah i think uh um it's very hard to know what living there would be like um but yeah it is super fun I've been there a couple of times. I had a blast. All right. Next biggest tech prediction. Real quick before that question. So James B. James B. has been a patron for I don't know how many months, but he's he's pledged a total of one hundred dollars on the dot. So thank you so much, James B., for all of your months of contribution there. And you are our first winner. So we will send you a T-shirt. You actually don't have your address on Patreon.
曼哈顿旅游每次都很棒，每次去我都会想：“也许，也许我们搬到这里来住吧？”但我觉得搬到一个地方住和去那里旅游是体验一座城市的两种非常不同的方式。对，对，完全同意。我觉得，嗯，嗯，要知道在那儿生活会是什么样真的很难。不过，那里的确超级好玩。我去过好几次了。我玩得非常开心。好的。下一个最大的科技预测。在回答那个问题之前，我们先插播一下。詹姆斯·B.（James B.）。詹姆斯·B.成为赞助人已经有几个月了，具体几个月我记不清了，但他一共认捐了一百美元整。所以非常感谢詹姆斯·B.这几个月来的所有捐助。你是我们的第一位获奖者。所以我们会给你寄一件T恤。其实你在Patreon上没有留下你的地址。
So I'm going to try and track you down from your email. If you're listening to this and you want to be proactive, shoot me an email with your address. Or any James B.'s that match that query pattern. Well, yeah, actually, that's true. There's probably other James B's. So yeah, maybe just wait for me to email you. But James B, I'm going to email you and we'll get your address and get a t-shirt over to you.
所以我要试着通过你的电子邮件来找到你。如果你正在听这个节目，并且想主动一点，发一封附带你地址的电子邮件给我。或者任何符合这个查询模式的詹姆斯·B.都可以。好吧，其实，这倒也是真的。可能还有别的詹姆斯·B.。所以，好吧，也许等我给你发邮件吧。不过詹姆斯·B.，我会给你发邮件，我们拿到你的地址后就把T恤寄给你。
Thanks for sponsoring the show. All right. Speaking of James, Clever Clover, aka James, is wanting to know our next biggest tech prediction. Next biggest. OK, I'll say this. My next biggest tech prediction is I think this decentralized web thing is actually going to take off. I mean, there's been like there's been all these things. Yeah, there's been like peer NFTs, baby. Let's go. Oh, my God. We should talk about nfts we should actually do a whole show on nfts we yeah it's 2021 and we didn't talk about nfts yet
感谢你赞助本节目。好的。说到詹姆斯，聪明的克洛弗（Clever Clover），也就是詹姆斯，想知道我们对下一个最大科技预测的看法。下一个最大的。好吧，我这么说吧。我下一个最大的科技预测是，我觉得这个去中心化的网络将真正腾飞。我是说，之前有过各种各样的事情。对，有过各种各样的事情。对，就像NFTs，宝贝。我们冲吧。哦，天哪。我们真该聊聊NFTs，我们真该做一整期关于NFTs的节目。对，现在是2021年，而我们居然还没聊过NFTs。
yeah you know it's not because i i've been consuming a lot of content on nfts but part of it was i was looking for a good interviewer and part of it was um you know i just don't really know where it's going to go but but but think that this sort of decentralized, like you have a box in your house that has your personal data, like your vault. Oh, you mean something different, I see. Yes. Yeah. And so you're all kind of, you're kind of bringing your own data, your own infrastructure.
对，你知道的，这倒不是因为我没有关注NFTs的大量内容，部分原因是我一直在寻找一个好的采访对象，另一部分原因是我，嗯，我其实不太确定它会走向何方，但我确实觉得这种去中心化的形式，比如你家里有一个存有你个人数据的盒子，就像你的保险库一样。哦，你是说另一种东西，我明白了。是的。对。所以大家都在某种程度上，相当于自带数据，自带基础设施。
And it's kind of, this is kind of like web 3.0. You know, I really think that that is going to take off. NFTs, you know, could be like ICOs or it's a big fad and people lose a lot of money. I'm not totally committed to NFTs, but I think Web 3.0 as a concept is going to take off. Interesting. I mean, I think I am always saying that, but I believe it's true. I think SpaceX. I mean, I think SpaceX, if they can pull off getting Starship into orbit this year, which is their goal, and we can discuss Elon Musk as a person at some other time, but if they can pull off that goal, which there's a lot of people there besides him. But, you know, I think people just are underestimating how transformative getting that much. Like right now, you care about literally every ounce that goes to space. But you'll move to caring about like vaguely how much something weighs
而且这有点像是Web 3.0。你知道，我真的觉得那个概念要火了。NFTs嘛，你知道，可能就像ICO（首次代币发行）一样是一股狂热的风潮，人们会因此亏掉一大笔钱。我并不是完全押注于NFTs，但我认为Web 3.0作为一个概念将会腾飞。有意思。我是说，我觉得我一直在这么说，但我坚信这是真的。我认为SpaceX。我是说，我认为SpaceX如果今年能成功将星舰（Starship）送入轨道——这也是他们的目标，至于埃隆·马斯克这个人，我们以后可以另找时间讨论——但如果他们能实现这个目标（除了他之外，那里的还有很多人），但我认为人们只是低估了运送如此庞大载荷的变革意义。就像现在，你得计较送上太空的每一盎司重量。但以后你只会大致关注某东西有多重，
and the frequency which was so good. I think it'll just change so much right and we're starting to kind of people are starting to realize this with starlink i was having a conversation someone the other day if starlink which is satellite-based internet like gets to where it needs to be i mean you'll no longer be able to have censorship in countries that's effective because people can just get their internet beamed in from space like You won't be able to stop that like you can today That's gonna itself have huge implications to
以及发射频率。这真是太棒了。我觉得这会带来巨大的改变，对吧？人们开始通过星链（Starlink）意识到这一点。我前几天还在跟别人聊天，如果星链——也就是基于卫星的互联网——达到了预期的水平，那么你在那些国家将再也无法进行有效的网络审查，因为人们可以直接从太空接收互联网信号。你将无法像今天这样阻止它。这本身就会对
Like the political landscape in addition to just like being able to get internet everywhere, which would be amazing But like being able to you know Have that same access that we have literally from all oppressed governments in the world that's going to be a big deal and i think that's only like the beginning right like i think being able to we talked about a long long time ago bigelow space and like the inflatable space stations but now like that's that's like small stake stuff considering the payload that Starship could put into orbit, right? Yeah, and actually I think our predictions kind of dovetail really nicely because I feel like you have some, traditionally you've had a lot of monopolies.
政治格局产生巨大的影响，不仅仅是能让到处都有互联网那么简单，那固然很棒，而且还能让你（你知道的）拥有我们所享有的那种相同的网络访问权限，摆脱世界上所有受压迫政府的限制，这将是一件大事。而且我认为这仅仅是个开始，对吧？就像我们很久很久以前讨论过的毕格罗太空（Bigelow Space）和充气太空站一样，但现在，考虑到星舰能够送入轨道的载荷，那些都成了小巫见大巫，对吧？是的，而且实际上我觉得我们的预测非常契合，因为我觉得你有一些……传统上你有很多垄断现象。
And you're seeing, so for example, like crypto kind of breaks, a lot of financial monopolies cryptocurrency. And so yeah web 3.0 is all about kind of breaking some of those monopolies reducing the barrier to entry by kind of making things distributed so you don't need, you know, a YouTube sized budget to compete with YouTube. Um, and so, but then you, but then you get to the hardware issue. And so this, this is a way to sort of democratize that. So kind of, you combine these two, it's like now internet is ubiquitous, you know? Yeah. And you can access the internet from everywhere. No one can really shut it down unless they have space lasers. And, um, um, and then you build the, you know, the, the software infrastructure on top of that. It could be really powerful. All right. It's Paul asks, if we could standardize all the code there is out there to one particular language, which language would it be and why would it be Python? Oh, my gosh.
而你正在看到——例如，加密货币在某种程度上打破了许多金融垄断，加密货币就是这样。所以，是的，Web 3.0就是为了打破其中一些垄断，通过将事物分布式处理来降低进入门槛，这样你就不需要一个YouTube规模的预算去跟YouTube竞争了。嗯，所以，但接着你会遇到硬件问题。所以，这是一种将其民主化的方式。因此，当你把这两者结合起来，就好像现在互联网无处不在了，你知道吗？是的，你可以在任何地方访问互联网。除非他们拥有太空激光武器，否则没人能真正将其关闭。而且，嗯，嗯，然后你在此之上构建软件基础设施。这可能会非常强大。好了。保罗（Paul）问，如果我们能把现有的所有代码标准化为一种特定的语言会是哪种语言，为什么它会是Python？天哪。
So it's Paul officially is going to cause our programming throwdown at gmail.com inbox to blow up. So thanks for that, Paul. But yeah, I think, man, if you could. Okay, so that's a good question, Patrick. So if you personally, Patrick, could only pick one language, what language did you pick and why oh i mean this is a huge question right like if i was stuck on a desert island and i can only bring one programming language with me what would it be i mean probably like you know i don't know i don't know this is tough like from a convert standpoint i mean i'm most comfortable in c++ python sucks um and i but i mean i kind of want to say javascript like i feel if i was like all that like if we giant shuffled the world into whatever with javascript i could get my current job done but also get web stuff done so i kind of want to say that this is a tough question i don't know oh man that's a really good point i never thought about that.
所以，保罗这下可以说是彻底点燃了 programmingthrowdown@gmail.com 的收件箱了。所以谢谢你，保罗。不过，是的，我觉得，天哪，如果你能……好吧，这是一个好问题，帕特里克（Patrick）。所以，如果你个人，帕特里克，只能选择一种语言，你会选什么语言，为什么？哦，我是说，这是一个巨大的问题，对吧？如果我被困在一个荒岛上，只能带一种编程语言跟我去，会是什么语言？我是说，可能就像，你知道的，我不知道，我不知道，这太难了。从代码熟悉的角度来看，我是说我最习惯C++，Python太烂了，但，但我是说，我有点想选JavaScript。我觉得如果世界发生大洗牌，无论结果如何，有了JavaScript，我既能完成现在的工作，也能搞定网页相关的东西。所以我有点想选这个。这是一个难题，我不知道。哦，天哪，这是一个非常好的观点，我从来没想过这一点。
Like if I, if like the world turned upside down and like, what is the programming language most likely to like help me build inertia back up? I'm going with 68K assembly. You know, I'm going to go with, I'm going to stick with Python. I was originally thinking Python. And then, you know,'m gonna go with i'm gonna stick with python i was originally thinking python and then you know meredith who we had on the show a while back from anvil has has their whole anvil uh framework where you can um write python and then they transpile it to the web and so i guess if i had to pick one i would go with python like like i think all the stats stuff just you
如果我，如果世界颠倒了，哪种编程语言最有可能帮我重新积聚势头？我选68K汇编。你知道的，我选，我还是坚持选Python。我本来一开始想选Python的。然后，你知道的，我还是选，我坚持选Python。我本来一开始想选Python的，然后呢，你知道的，我们前段时间请到节目里做客的来自Anvil的梅雷迪思（Meredith），他们有整个Anvil框架，你可以在里面用Python编写代码，然后他们将其转译到网页端。所以我想如果我必须选一个，我会选Python，因为我觉得所有的统计分析资料都，
know all of the the um batteries that are included there okay what about if you could only well actually you already picked an old language right you picked some old assemblies just talking about that but no i mean actually python is good i mean python and javascript would be a pretty good toss up for like chance of being able to communicate with other people and like inertia and breadth the barrier to entry for a lot of other languages is is just high when it comes to the general populace and i think people get elitist like i mean i don't program c++ because that's an elitist thing but i mean i think there are people who would say something like assembly or haskell or whatever not because they truly believed it but in part to be elit. And then not everyone. Some people would generally die before giving up Lisp in their parentheses. But we're definitely getting flamed. I've always enjoyed writing code in C++.
你知道的，里面自带了所有的“电池”（功能齐全）。好吧，那如果你只能……其实你已经选了一种老旧语言了，对吧？你选了一些老旧的汇编语言，刚才也聊过了。不过，说真的，Python确实不错。Python和JavaScript算是不相上下吧，都有很大几率能与其他人沟通，并且具备不错的势头和广度。对于大众而言，许多其他语言的进入门槛实在太高了，而且人们往往会变得很精英主义——我是说，我不写C++，因为那是一种精英主义的东西。但我觉得确实有人会说诸如汇编或Haskell之类的话，倒不是因为他们真的信仰它们，而是部分为了表现得精英主义。当然，也不是所有人。有些人至死也不会放弃Lisp及其括号。不过我们肯定会被网友喷得很惨。我一直很喜欢用C++写代码。
I think there's something really satisfying about it. And I do like the fact that, well, now with Python python it's effectively you're getting that same feeling because the the type system depending on how you have that set up um but now with python you know and especially in a corporate environment you know you write the python i guess the difference is you can run the python when the types are all messed up but you can't actually submit a pull request it won't let you um in c++ like you can't you can't even get that far um and as far as like a legit old language i kind of mentioned it but i you know i don't program in lisp but lisp has been the one that i think
我觉得其中有种非常令人满足的感觉。而且我确实喜欢这样一点——好吧，现在用Python的话，你实际上也能获得那种相同的感受，因为类型系统取决于你的设置方式。但现在用Python，你知道的，尤其是在企业环境中，你写Python时——我想区别在于，当类型全乱套时你依然可以运行Python，但你实际上没法提交代码审查（PR），系统不让你这么干。而在C++中，你根本走不到那一步。至于那种正统的老旧语言，我刚才其实提到了，但你知道的，我不写Lisp，不过Lisp是我认为
has sort of stuck around the longest like it's old but it continues to be a place where they continue to have enthusiasm and support so other examples it's while we were like pascal fortran cobalt i mean those are used but mostly in sort of uh not active development but more sort of like maintenance aspects or very niche things whereas i think lisp still has like and derivatives there so there must be reasoning to that so even though i'm not a huge list proponent currently like i'll stick up for it from that aspect yep yep totally agree um yeah this is i'm a big fan of lisp i haven't written in it forever but i always have a good time so colin g colin g he um he's been a looks, he's been a,
存活时间最长的语言。它很古老，但它依然是一个人们持续保持热情和支持的领域。至于其他例子，虽然像Pascal、Fortran、Cobol也还在用，但主要不是用于积极的开发，而是更多地用于维护方面或者非常小众的领域。而我认为Lisp依然拥有（爱好者）以及衍生版本，所以这背后一定有其道理。因此，尽管我目前并不是一个坚定的Lisp拥护者，但我会从这个角度为它说句公道话。对，对，完全同意。嗯，是的，我是Lisp的超级粉丝，虽然我很久没用它写过代码了，但用它总是很愉快。那么，科林·G.（Colin G.），科林·G.，他，看起来，
it looks like he's been a patron for a little over a year. So thanks, Colin. And Colin also doesn't have his address. So I'm going to have to track him down, but, but Colin's going to, you want to come into your house. That's right. Do you want a t-shirt? I just need you to send me your address and your credit card so you can pay for it and your social. No so call and g want a t-shirt i'll track you down call and g and get you your t-shirt so thanks again for supporting the show um so um necrois necrois necrois says asks um if you could redo your career and education path what would you
他成为赞助人已经有一年多了。所以谢谢你，科林。而且科林也没有留下他的地址。所以我得想办法找到他。不过，科林要，你这是想私闯民宅吗？没错。你想想要一件T恤吗？我只需要你把地址和信用卡号发给我，这样你就能付钱了，还有你的社保号。不用。所以，科林·G.想要一件T恤，科林·G.，我会找到你的，把T恤送给你。所以再次感谢你支持本节目。嗯，那么，克罗伊斯（necrois），克罗伊斯，克罗伊斯问，如果你能重新选择你的职业和教育道路，你会
change um that's an interesting question um well patrick you got your master's online what was your feeling would you change that or were you happy with that so i mean i guess like this is going to be the broken record patrick tonight but i mean for me like you know i didn't you know look this is controversial so i you know i'll say what worked for me which is i went to a state university i know jason you did too but yep but i went to a state university um that left me in Florida. That state university system in Florida was, I think, a very good value, at least when I went. I haven't kept track of what it is anymore. But when I went, that was a really good value. And I even got scholarships and stuff, so it cost even less. But even at in-state full price, that was a good value. I came out with
改变什么？这是一个有趣的问题。嗯，帕特里克，你是在网上读的硕士，你当时有什么感想？你会改变那个决定，还是对它感到满意？所以，我是说，这听起来可能又要变成帕特里克今晚的老生常谈了，但对我和我的经历来说，你知道的，我没有……看，这可能会引发争议，所以我只说对我有用的做法：我上了一所州立大学。我知道杰森你也是，对吧？是的。但我的确上了一所州立大学，
a very good financial situation, got a good job out of it. That worked really well for me. I don't think I would change my education path there. And the career I get in, no, I mean, I'm super happy that like, we discussed the whole Silicon Valley thing. I think that's worked out well. Now, there's a lot of timing, luck, serendipity, whatever you want to call it. You know, if you're a subscriber to Malcolm Gladwell kind of things, you can go sort of read his take on that. But like, you know, I'm not saying other people could could repeat what I did. But, you know, I think I've been happy.
那所大学给我的经济负担很小，至少在我去读的时候是这样。我没有再关注现在的情况了。但当年我去的时候，那真的是性价比极高。我甚至还拿到了奖学金什么的，所以花销更少。即便按州内全价学费计算，那也是相当划算的。我毕业时
I will be careful to say how much of it is repeatable versus happenstance. But yeah, I did my master's degree while working. And the broken record part of this is like, if I knew how much work it was going to be when I started doing it, I'm not sure I would like people ask me today, like that I work with, should I do my master's degree? Like you did your master's degree while you were working? Should I? And I have a hard time answering them. I'm thankful I did it. I feel like it's one of those, if you ever don't get a job, you never know if it would have helped or not. But I don't think it
的财务状况非常不错，毕业后也找到了一份好工作。这对我很管用。我不认为我会改变我当时的教育道路。至于我从事的职业，不，我是说，我超级高兴，我们之前讨论过整个硅谷的事，我觉得那一切结果都很好。当然，这其中有很大一部分成分是时机、运气、机缘巧合，无论你想怎么称呼它。如果你是马尔科姆·格拉德威尔（Malcolm Gladwell）那类理论的信徒，你可以去读读他对这方面的看法。但我想说的是，我并不是说其他人能够复制我走的路。不过，你知道的，我觉得我一直挺开心的。
like made me that much of a better programmer, to be honest. So I'm glad I have it. I wouldn't do it now. And I'm kind of proud that it's like on my resume. And I'm glad that I was getting real world experience rather than delaying getting that experience in order to do it. And I'm glad that I was getting real world experience rather than delaying getting that experience in order to do it. And so for me, that worked really well. And I'm thankful I have it. But I'm not 100% sure it's worth it today in at least the field I'm in. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I mean, I think I think that makes a lot of sense. I think it depends on your sort of values. Yeah, I would agree that getting a master's or a higher level degree, you probably, you barely break even if at all. That wouldn't surprise me. But I always wanted to do like really high level math. That's just something I wanted to do.
我会谨慎地评估，其中究竟有多少是可以复制的，又有多少纯属偶然。不过，是的，我是边工作边读硕士的。而这其中老生常谈的部分就是：如果我在开始读硕士之前就知道需要付出那么多精力，我真不确定自己还会不会去读。现在常有人问我——比如和我一起共事的同事——“我该不该去读硕士？你当年就是边工作边读的，我该去吗？”我很难回答他们。我很庆幸自己读了。我觉得这就像是一种心理安慰：如果你没有得到某份工作，你永远不知道学位是否发挥了作用。但我并不认为它
And I felt like, you know, even if it paid the same. And so I was starting my career later and, you know, there was there was that compounding effect. You know, at the end of the day, it's like I just that's the kind of job I want to do. And so, you know, I just I just felt like I needed to have more sort of, you know, kind of job I want to do. And so, um, um, you know, I just, I just felt like I needed to have more sort of, you know, kind of like training and I wanted to learn, you know, more about, about how to do that. And a lot of the advanced math classes are hard to take and all of that. And so that was my master's. And then for PhD, I got into the PhD because I wanted to have neural networks play go.
让我成为了一个好得多的程序员，说实话。所以我很高兴我有这个学位。如果现在让我选，我不会再去读了。而且我挺自豪它能写在我的简历上。我也很高兴自己当时积累的是真实世界的经验，而不是为了读书而推迟获取那些经验。所以我很高兴自己当时是在积累真实世界的经验，而不是为了读书而推迟获取那些经验。因此对我而言，这非常管用。我很庆幸自己拥有这个学位。但我并不百分之百确定它在当今——至少在我所处的领域——是否真的物有所值。嗯，这倒也是。对，我是说，我觉得这完全说得通。我觉得这取决于你的价值观。是的，我也认同，读硕士或更高学位，你大概只能勉强回本，甚至可能都回不了本。对此我一点也不会感到意外。但我一直想研究非常高阶的数学。那只是我个人想做的事。
And it was at the time a really, really hard problem. And it took years and I made like just a fraction of the progress, but I made something. At some point, like I think after you write like three journal papers, then you can kind of graduate. And so by like the second journal paper, I was pretty done. I mean, I was kind of ready to, you know, to go get a job or be a professor. I didn't know what, but I wanted to finish my PhD. So yeah, I mean, I think that's, that was really the reasoning there. And so, you know, I wouldn't, yeah, I wouldn't really change
而且我觉得，哪怕薪水完全一样，我也愿意去学。所以，我当时开始职业生涯的时间较晚，你知道的，这其中存在复合效应。但归根结底，这就是我想做的工作。所以，你知道的，我只是觉得自己需要接受更多种类的培训，并且我想了解更多关于如何进行那类研究的知识。而且许多高级数学课很难选到，诸如此类。这就是我的硕士经历。至于博士学位，我读博是因为我想让神经网络去下围棋。
anything. I think you have a good point there to interject a bit, like you said, to get to the kind of things you wanted to do and i think that is a good point there are certain parts of certain fields that have different expectations like it's been my experience listening to you and other people for instance like to really hit the ground running in machine learning for instance i think like there is more door, there are more doors open to you if you have a PhD, at least today, then not versus like for me and the kind of work that I'm doing, you know, maybe like a more embedded slant or whatever. This is not a thing like a master's degree, a PhD, years of experience, like they're kind of all interchangeable. You're not going to get like
在当时，这是一个非常非常难的问题。我花了几年时间，只取得了微乎其微的进展，但我确实做出了点成果。到某个阶段，我想大概是在你写了三篇期刊论文之后，你就可以毕业了。所以到了第二篇期刊论文左右，我已经差不多完成了。我是说，我已经准备好去谋求一份工作或成为一名教授了。我当时不知道具体会做什么，但我想要完成博士学业。所以，是的，这就是背后的真正原因。因此，你知道的，我不会，是的，我不会真正改变
more benefit of the doubt or more access by having higher level degrees. Yep. I also worked all through grad school, actually through undergrad as well, but not full-time through undergrad. But yeah, I mean, I think working while you're in grad school is a great idea. It helps you kind of stay focused. If it takes an extra year, I think that's fine. You know, I don't know if finishing a year earlier would have really changed anything. So, yeah, I think working for me was actually really important. Helped kind of keep me grounded.
任何事。你刚才说得挺有道理的，我稍微插一句。正如你所说，为了去做自己想做的事——我觉得这很有道理。某些领域的某些部分有着不同的期望。根据我听你和其他人交流的经验，举个例子，要想在机器学习领域真正一上手就能大显身手，如果你有博士学位，相比没有博士学位的人来说，你会发现有更多的门为你敞开，至少在今天是这样。而对于我和我正在从事的工作而言，可能更偏向于嵌入式方向或者其他什么。这并不意味着像硕士学位、博士学位、多年的经验这些东西是可以完全互换的。你并不会因为拥有更高阶的学位就自动获得更多的信任或更多的机会。对。我在读研究生期间也一直在工作，其实本科时也是如此，不过本科期间不是全职。但，是的，我觉得在读研期间工作是个绝佳的主意。它能帮你保持专注。如果因此多花了一年时间，我觉得也没问题。你知道的，我不知道早一年毕业是否真的会改变什么。所以，是的，对我来说，工作其实非常重要。它帮我保持脚踏实地，
And I learned a lot of software discipline and things like that. That I don't think I would have learned if I just tried to go straight through without having a job. M2N m2nc oh do you want another giveaway or we want to go to the next question uh let's do it all right so so matt uh i almost said matt's last name and we'd have to clip that out matt i matt's letter i um you are a t-shirt winner and we have your address. I'll probably still email you just to confirm that Matt I is in great Britain. Oh, nice. He's been a patron for, it looks like about a year and a half. And so thank you so much, Matt, for your support. And we will get a t-shirt over to you.
而且我学到了许多软件开发规范之类的东西。如果我当时没有工作，只是试图一气呵成地读完书，我是绝对学不到这些的。M2N，M2nc，你是想要另一个抽奖环节，还是想直接进入下一个问题？我们来吧！好的，那么——马特（Matt），我差点说出了马特（Matt）的姓氏，那样我们就得把那部分剪掉了——马特·I.（Matt I.），你是T恤得主，我们有你的地址。我可能还是会给你发封电子邮件，只是为了确认这位马特·I.是否身在英国。哦，太棒了！他成为赞助人大概有一年半的时间了。所以非常感谢马特对我们的支持，我们会把T恤寄给你的。
Nice. All right. for your support and we will get a t-shirt over to you nice all right mqnc's question is what is the dirtiest hackiest anti-patternist um sp piece of code you ever wrote in full conscious and even maybe enjoying the thrill and why was it the way to go well we both wrote some really ugly code when we worked together i remember actually i'll tell you a really quick story i remember we built this prototype so we were working in a research lab and so we were trying to produce little prototypes they weren't production worthy systems by any stretch and we had this prototype and this and at the time i mean i was still in grad school we were both still in school. And so we didn't have a lot of experience. And I was creating a process. I think it was like every second.
太棒了！好的。感谢你的支持，我们会把T恤寄给你的。太棒了！好的。M2nc的问题是：你曾经写过的最烂、最充满黑客手段（hacky）、最违反反模式（anti-pattern）的垃圾代码是什么？你是在完全清醒的情况下写的吗？甚至可能还享受着那种刺激感？为什么当时那样做是正确的选择？我们俩在一起工作时都写过一些非常丑的代码。其实我记得一个非常短小的故事，我讲来听听。我记得我们当时做过这样一个原型：我们在一个研究实验室工作，所以我们试图产出一些小原型，它们在任何意义上都不是可用于生产系统的代码。我们当时有这样一个原型，而且当时——我还正在读研究生，我们都还在学校里。
So basically there was a batch of work that needed to get done. And for every batch, instead of having like a pool of processes and using like the multi-processing library in Python and just feeding it all to the pool, I was creating a process for every item in the batch. Now I had like a semaphore, so it wasn't, you know, if there were 10,000 batches, it wasn't creating 10,000 processes all at once, you know, but it was creating, let's say five processes. And when the first one finished, it was creating a sixth process. And so, and so basically we could only do something like
所以我们当时没有太多经验。我当时在创建一个进程。我记得好像是每秒钟……
10 000 batches before the machine died because it was just creating processes and it wasn't cleaning them up um so that that happened the thing that kind of comes to my mind here is that you know when you don't really know what the final product is going to look like, that is when I build really hacky things. And so that's when I feel like it's the way to go. Because the design is changing a lot, the structure is changing a lot. And so I'll write something really ugly. It might be like one massive, you know, IPython notebook or something. And then in hindsight, you know, I'll look at it and it'll be terrible and it'll need to be rewritten. But I still feel like that made the most sense. You know, one thing that actually I talked to
基本上有一批任务需要完成。对于每一批任务，我没有采用进程池并使用Python中的多进程（multiprocessing）库把所有任务丢给进程池的做法，而是为批次中的每一个项目都创建一个进程。当然，我设置了一个信号量，所以如果有一万个批次，它不会一下子创建一万个进程，但它会创建比如说五个进程。当第一个进程完成时，它会创建第六个进程。因此，基本上我们只能处理大约
the creator of iPython notebook. I'm terrible at names, but he works for Amazon now for AWS. And he's actually a physics professor. A physics professor created iPython Notebook. And he said something really interesting. He said, you know, when I, and this is, I'm using his language here. He said, when I open Visual Studio, the verb that I would call
一万个批次，机器就会崩溃，因为它一直在创建进程却没有清理它们。所以……类似的情况发生了。我脑海中浮现出的是：当你真的不知道最终的产品会是什么样的时候，正是在那种时候我会写出非常投机取巧的代码。而且我觉得在那种情况下，这样做就是对的。因为设计在不断变化，结构也在不断变化。所以我就会写一些非常丑的代码。它可能是一个无比庞大的IPython Notebook或者别的什么。事后回想起来，你会发现它简直糟透了，必须重写。但我依然觉得在当时那是最佳选择。你知道，我曾跟
for what I'm doing in Visual Studio is build. You know, I'm building a library. I'm building a library. I'm building a website. He's like, but when I open IPython, the verb I like to use is tinker. It's like I'm tinkering with something. Or even better is like think. I'm thinking about something. And so I think there's times when you're trying to understand something or trying to think about something. And that's where you'll write some ugly code um and and it'll help you be really agile but then when you're done thinking and it's time to build something then that's that's a struggle because then you have
IPython Notebook的创造者交流过。我不擅长记名字，但他现在在亚马逊的AWS工作。其实他是一位物理学教授。一位物理学教授创造了IPython Notebook。他说了一件非常有意思的事。他说：“当我和——我在这里用他的原话——他说：‘当我打开Visual Studio时，对于我在里面做的事情，我称之为「构建」（build）。’”你知道的，“我在构建一个库，我在构建一个网站。”他说，“但是当我打开IPython时，我喜欢用的动词是「瞎琢磨」（tinker）。就像我在捣鼓什么东西。或者更好一点的词是「思考」（think）。我在思考某些事情。”所以我觉得有时候当你试图理解什么事情或者思考什么事情时，就会写出一些丑陋的代码，
to convince everyone to rewrite it interesting um i mean look i come from a background of like cnc plus plus i won't tell you the number of times where i needed to do string formatting and look i ain't got no batteries included string formatting library so a number of s printfs and you know some slapdashy iterative pointer with modification like code comes out because i know how to do it and i know it'll be right and everyone else looks at it and is like what it's like no just just go with it it's fine what are you doing here i'm stripping spaces like just just don't even just like keep going and the same thing happens every so often anything that slightly resembles like image processing where like you end up with like two loops, like an outer loop over rows and inner loop over columns.
而这能帮你保持极高的敏捷性。但一旦你思考完了，到了该构建某些东西的时候，那就会变成一场苦战，因为你得说服所有人去重写它。有意思。我是说，你看，我出身于C++背景。我简直数不清自己有多少次需要做字符串格式化，而你知道的，我手头又没有自带的字符串格式化库。于是各种 `sprintf`，还有各种东拼西凑的、带修改的迭代指针代码就这么诞生了，因为我知道该怎么写，而且我知道写出来是对的。而其他人看到就会一脸茫然：“这是什么鬼？”我说：“不不不，别管它，能跑就行。你在这干嘛呢？”“我在去除空格。”“行了，别纠结了，继续往前看。”类似的情况经常发生。任何稍微有点像图像处理的事情——比如你最终写出了双重循环，外层循环遍历行，内层循环遍历列——
I end up busting out some amount of pointer math and doing something that people just groan and are just like, what are you doing, Patrick? They're like, no, no, it's fine. And every time, which comes up fairly often, everyone knows like, hey, I need to do some bit manipulation. And they just come to me and then it's like yeah yeah okay i'll do this for you what was one oh we needed to like write a very partial parser for some unicode encoding stuff which of course like c++ probably has a library for somewhere but we just needed a subset so like dropping into the bit math and like deciding when you needed to continue on to like a one byte two byte or three byte or four
我最后都会祭出一堆指针数学运算，搞出一些让别人直叹气、满脸写着“帕特里克你在干什么呢？”的代码。他们会说：“不不不，没事的。”每次——这种情况经常出现——大家都知道：“嘿，我需要做一些位操作。”然后他们就会来找我，接着我就说：“行吧行吧，我来给你写。”其中有一个例子是：我们需要为一个某些Unicode编码写一个非常局部的解析器。当然，C++可能在某个地方自带了相应的库，但我们只需要其中一小部分。所以直接切入位运算，判断什么时候需要继续推进到一字节、两字节、三字节或四
byte unicode encoding like you know just like hacking that crap out as like bit shift operations and you know some pointer math uh yeah that i i don know. I'm kind of proud of it because in my head, somehow the bits move and it works, but I've never successfully explained that code to anyone else. You know, there's this IQ test called Raven's matrices. Have you heard of this?
字节的Unicode编码，你知道的，就把那堆破代码当成位移操作和一些指针数学运算给硬生生地敲出来了。是的，我对此还挺骄傲的。因为在我的脑海里，不知怎么的，这些二进制位就是按照预期在移动，代码也确实能跑通。但我从来没能成功向其他人解释过那段代码。你知道有一个叫瑞文矩阵（Raven's matrices）的智商测试吗？你听说过吗？
No. So it's basically this really complicated pattern matching, and it's been heralded as, you know, oh my my god i mean we could spend like a whole show or multiple shows talking about iq tests and that whole thing but but um you know one of the nice things about raven's matrices is that you don't have to know any particular language and um it's supposed to be like a pretty pure test of like visuospatial
没有。所以它基本上是一种非常复杂的模式匹配测试，并被誉为……天哪，我们可以花整整一期或好几期节目来聊智商测试和那档子事。但不管怎样，瑞文矩阵的好处之一在于你不需要掌握任何特定的语言，
intelligence i have this feeling from just knowing you for many years that you would like get a high score on raven's matrices i'm gonna look it up and i'm definitely not gonna try it i have a kind of a follow-up it seems like the work you're doing it just surprises me that it's done in c++ is that what was the the reason i mean i know that i don't want to like dive into like your day job but yeah like uh did someone just make the call and say we're going to write all of this in c++ i mean i think it's like we like the stuff i'm doing right now is like a library to other stuff so so we write a bunch of library for moving moving data around and doing really efficient like really tuned stuff because of the scale we work at like to other stuff. So we write a bunch of library for moving data around
而且它应该算是一个相当纯粹的视觉空间智能测试。根据我认识你多年的直觉，我觉得你在瑞文矩阵测试中能拿到高分。我要去查查看，但我绝对不会去试的。我还有一个后续问题。鉴于你现在做的工作，我总是很惊讶这居然是用C++完成的。这就是当时的理由吗？我是说，我知道我不想深入探讨你的日常工作，但，是的，是有人直接拍板决定说“我们要用C++来写所有代码”吗？我是说，我觉得这就像——我们现在做的事情是一个底层库，为其他东西提供支持。所以我们编写了一堆用于移动数据、进行极其高效且深度调优操作的库，因为我们处理的规模非常庞大。不是分布式的，而是在单机系统上。哦，我明白了。所以因为其他需要调用我们的代码是用C++编写的，我们某种程度上也必须使用C++。然后，当我们编写与自身基础设施对接的代码时，最显而易见的选择
and doing really efficient, really tuned stuff because of the scale we work at. Not distributedly, but on a single system. Oh, I see. And so because other people who need to call us are in C++, we kind of have to be in C++. Then when we need to write our own interfacing to our infrastructure, it's most obvious
就是直接用C++编写，否则你就得写某种导出器——当然我们偶尔也会这么做，把数据导出为JSON，或者通过PyBind绑定之类的，对吧？这就说得通了。所以Lidl问，对服务器端渲染的React和Next.js有什么看法？什么？你刚才已经聊过这个了！剧透警告！哦，对。是的。我是说，这真是……天哪，这简直是“预叙”（foreshadowing）的反义词。这叫“后叙”（backshadowing）。但我显然是Next.js的超级粉丝。不过我会聊聊服务器端渲染。我对服务器端渲染其实并不是很感冒。所以我简单讲个背景故事。前段时间，谷歌发布了一份报告。报告中提到的一点是，谷歌搜索结果每加载延迟毫秒，他们就会流失相应数量的用户。换句话说，他们做过一个
to just write in C++, or else you have to write some sort of exporter, which we do do occasionally. Exports us out to JSON, or PyBinded, or whatever, right? That makes sense. So Lidl asks, thoughts on server-side rendering React
测试，人为地增加了一点延迟。哪怕只是增加了10毫秒的延迟，也会让谷歌损失惨重——你知道的，一切都是建立在如此庞大的体量之上的。所以这让谷歌付出了巨额的代价。因此他们展示了网站必须具备极高的响应速度，甚至精确到毫秒级。所以服务器端渲染——这里有不同的方式，比如预渲染：如果你的网站永远不会改变，比如你的最终用户许可协议（EULA）或类似的东西，你只需要在服务器端渲染一次，然后客户端就再也不需要重新渲染了，你只是在服务器端完成渲染并发送结果。还有，也许你可以预先计算其中一小部分，甚至很大一部分，但不是全部。你知道的，我并不完全确信SSR像人们吹嘘的那样重要。所以，是的，我得承认我对这一点持怀疑态度。但Next.js太棒了。我觉得每个人都应该使用它。当然可能还有其他替代方案。所以我绝不是前端专家。但我的经历是从用React编写代码，然后用Flask或类似框架搭建网站，转变为在Next中搞定整个浏览器端和服务器端。我发现那体验太棒了。所以其他类似Next的工具可能会更好，
and Next.js? What's that? You already covered this! Spoiler alert! Oh, yeah. Yeah. I mean, this is wow. This is what is the opposite of foreshadowing? This is backshadowing. But I'm obviously a huge fan of Next.js. But I'll talk about server side rendering. I am not really sold on server side rendering. So I'll give a quick backstory here. A while back, Google released this report. And one of the things the report said was that for every so many milliseconds it takes Google's results to show up, they lose that many people. So in other words, they did a
但这种开发范式，我觉得太棒了。我无可奉告，不是因为它充满争议，而是因为它离我的领域太远了。好了，接下来是格伦·S.（Glenn S.）。格伦·S.是我们的下一位获奖者。同样没有留下地址，所以我不知道你来自哪里。哦，天哪。不过格伦·S.成为会员已经有很长时间了，这些年来他已经贡献了300多美元。所以，是的，非常感谢格伦对本节目的支持，我们真的非常非常
test where they artificially added a little delay. And even just adding a 10 millisecond delay cost Google, you know, and everything is at this extraordinary scale, right? So it cost Google a bazillion dollars. And so they showed how, you know, sites have to be as responsive as possible, even down to the millisecond. And so server side rendering, and there's different ways. I mean, there's pre-rendering, where if you have a website that's never, a site that's never going to change, like imagine your end user license agreement or something, you just render that once and then you never have to render it again client you're just doing it on the server and then sending the result and there's and like maybe you can pre-compute like a tiny bit of it or even a lot of it but not all of it and you know i'm not totally convinced that ssr is as important as people are making it out to be so yeah i have to admit i'm a little skeptical of that. But Next.js is amazing. I think everyone should be using it. And there's probably alternatives. So I'm by no means a front end expert. But I went from, you know, writing in React and then a website in, you know, Flask or one of these things to just doing the whole thing, browser and server in Next. And I found that amazing. And so other things that do similar to Next might be better,
感激，我们会把T恤寄给你的。鸭子麦克（MC Platypus）问：对可视化编程语言LabVIEW有什么看法？我对此一无所知。你知道吗？哦，真的吗？对，其实我知道。我可以顺便切入这个话题。我确实用LabVIEW写过代码。
but that paradigm, I think, is awesome. I have no comment, not because it's controversial, but because it's too far from me. All right. So we have Glenn S. Glenn S is our next winner. Also, no address address so i don't know where you're from oh wow but glenn s has been a member for a very long time he's contributed over 300 dollars over the years so yeah thank you so much glenn um for supporting the show we really really
其实，这正是那种你觉得理所当然，结果却发现自己跟其他人有点不一样的情况——我经常遇到这种事。我觉得每个人都会遇到这种情况吧？你总以为别人都跟你差不多，对吧？或者至少我是这么认为的……也许这种想法本身就是一个假设？哦，这可就深奥了，等等，我正在经历存在主义危机。你有……这叫“假设套假设”（assumption-ception）吗？天哪，回来，回来，回来！好吧，所以这既是一个更广泛的故事，也是一个具体的故事。我曾经用LabVIEW写过一些代码，具体是一些控制循环的代码。而且，你知道的，这就是那种每个人都会说“哦，无代码”的领域。
appreciate it and we will get a t-shirt over to you. MC Platypus says, any thoughts on the visual programming language LabVIEW? I don't know anything about it. Do you know anything? Oh, really? Yeah, I do, actually. And I'll segue. So I have done programming in LabVIEW.
非常感谢，我们会给你寄一件T恤。MC Platypus问，对可视化编程语言LabVIEW有什么看法？我对它一无所知。你了解吗？哦，真的吗？是的，我确实了解。我顺便说一下。所以，我用LabVIEW进行过编程。
Actually, this is one of those things where i guess i sort of take it for granted and then it turns out like you're a bit different than everyone else like this happens to me every so often i think everyone this happens right like you just assume people are kind of like you right um or at least i do um the maybe that's an assumption itself oh this goes deep hang on i'm having an existential crisis um you have uh what is it assumption ception oh gosh uh come back come back come back okay so it is like a broader story specific story so i wrote some code actually some control loop stuff in lab view and um you know it's one of those things where everyone says oh no code you
实际上，这正是那种我会觉得这理所当然，然后结果却发现你和大家有点不一样的事情，这种情况我经常遇到，我想每个人都会遇到这种情况吧？就像你只是假设别人和你的情况差不多，对吧？嗯，或者至少我是这么认为的，也许这本身就是一个假设。哦，这有点深奥了，等等，我正在经历存在主义危机。你有一种，这是什么？假设套假设？天哪，回来，回来，回来。好吧，所以这是一个更广泛的故事，具体的故事是这样的：我写了一些代码，实际上是LabVIEW中的一些控制回路代码，嗯，你知道的，这是那种每个人都说“哦，无代码”的领域
can do this stuff in lab view and then i look at it and i'm like this is just coding like even with debugging just like without the scary with like pictures and arrows and not the like curly braces or white space that are your you know control, control flows. And so I think like, I don't know, like it's, it's, everyone says it's kind of different, but then it doesn't end up being all that different. At least I don't approach it all that different. Like I end up doing it really similarly, but I think this is held across other things in my experience. Like for an example, that's pertinent to like my background is i wrote some c code but i wrote my c code very much like i write my c++ code but a lot of people who write c code don't write it in
完全可以在LabVIEW里做这种东西，然后我看着它就会想，这不就是编程吗，甚至连调试也是，只是没有了那些可怕的东西，而是用图片和箭头代替，没有了大括号或空白字符来做你的控制流。所以我觉得，每个人都说它挺不一样的，但到头来其实也没那么大不同。至少我的处理方式没那么大不同。我最终的做法其实非常相似，但我觉得根据我的经验，这种看法也适用于其他事情。比如，有一个例子跟我自己的背景很贴切，我写过一些C代码，但我写C代码的方式很像我写C++代码的方式，不过很多写C代码的人并不是以这种
that style they write it in a completely different style so to me i didn't find that much difference but a lot of people do stuff in a very different style, which makes like, for instance, type safety stuff much harder to do. And so they just lean all in on it not being type safe, or less type safe, I should say. And so I think LabVIEW can be a bit more similar than it is different. I don't think it's some great thing. I mean, but I guess what I would say about it is it's an example of the reason why i got into programming it is there was a piece of hardware that needed uh some code written to control it and i could have said you know there were i think c++ bindings for the drivers and
风格来写的，他们用的是完全不同的风格。所以对我来说，我没觉得有太大区别，但很多人用非常迥异的风格来做事，这就会让某些事情变得很难，比如类型安全性。因此他们就完全不顾类型安全，或者说没那么类型安全。所以我觉得LabVIEW其实是大同小异的。我不觉得它是什么了不起的东西。不过，如果要我说的话，它是促使我开始编程的一个例子：当时有一块硬件需要编写一些代码来控制它，我本来可以说——我想驱动程序有C++的绑定之类的，
stuff but the person already had been up and fiddling it in LabVIEW. And so using the right tool for the right job, it was my call that the right tool was to just keep doing what they needed in LabVIEW, which was taking some input and controlling some system, some hardware, because they already had the parts that I knew would be most difficult to do like interfacing with drivers and all that stuff already taken care of and so the work at hand was easier for me to adapt to the tool than to bring my own tool set and I think that's something that I take with me a lot of places like a joke of like Jason asked me like why are you using c++ or whatever which slightly different but like you know if it calls for Python i'll use python if it calls for javascript i'll use javascript like i may not be the best at those but like i think a lot of people spend a lot more time adapting the problem to where they're comfortable than to meeting the problem where it is yep that makes sense i've been burned actually by WYSIWYG twice. Although, you know, for doing desktop apps, it's amazing. So if you're using Qt, the Qt creator or Qt designer, I think they rebranded it,
但对方已经开始在LabVIEW里上手折腾了。所以本着为工作选择最合适工具的原则，我当时决定，最合适的工具就是继续用LabVIEW帮他们完成所需的功能，也就是接收一些输入并控制某个系统或硬件，因为他们已经把那些我知道做起来最困难的部分（比如与驱动程序交互等等）都处理好了，所以对我来说，适应这个工具比带入我自己的工具集要轻松得多。我觉得这一点在很多地方我都一直在践行。就像Jason开玩笑问我：“你为什么用C++之类的呀？”虽然情况略有不同，但你看，如果需要Python，我就会用Python；如果需要JavaScript，我就会用JavaScript。我可能不是那些语言的最优使用者，但我认为很多人花在调整问题以迎合自己舒适区的时间，远多于去直面问题本身的时间。是的，这说得通。其实我两次被所见即所得（WYSIWYG）工具坑过。不过，你知道的，在做桌面应用时，它简直太棒了。所以如果你用Qt，比如Qt creator或者Qt designer（我想他们现在改名了），
where you basically have this visual thing and then it auto generates a bunch of Python code and you can kind of fill in. Or I think now you extend the class that they auto-generate, but you effectively fill in the functions. I think that's amazing. Works really well. I haven't seen anything like that for the web,
你基本上可以在上面进行可视化的设计，然后它会自动生成一大堆Python代码，你只需要在里面填充逻辑就行了。或者我觉得现在你是去扩展他们自动生成的类，但实际上你就是在填充函数。我觉得这太棒了。效果非常好。我没在网页开发中见过类似的东西，
but that could work if it existed. But I use this tool called, Patrick, you might've used this too, called PowerDrill, which was this WYSIWYG thing where you drag and drop boxes with little logic blocks in them. And basically what it would do is build a giant SQL statement for you. And so then you would build this flow in PowerDrill, and then you'd press go, and it would just turn that into a SQL command and run it. And then they deprecated it and then they ended up killing it. And so I ended up having to, and this, of course, like any WYSIWYG tool,
但如果存在的话，应该也能行。不过我用过一个叫PowerDrill的工具——帕特里克，你可能也用过——它就是一个所见即所得的工具，你可以通过拖放带有小型逻辑块的方框来使用。它的基本功能是为你构建一个巨大的SQL语句。所以你会在PowerDrill里构建这个流程，然后点击运行，它就会把这个流程转换成SQL命令并执行。后来他们弃用了这个工具，最后把它下线了。于是我不得不——当然啦，和任何所见即所得的工具一样，
the SQL it generates is totally unreadable and atrocious. So I ended up having to redo all of my work, you know, writing those SQL queries by hand. And then I went to another company much later and made exactly the same mistake where they had a tool called, it was called Data Swarm. So Data Swarm was this tool where you could write a bunch of SQL and you could write it in blocks. So you could write a SQL command and then instead of having all these nested SQL commands, which gets really ugly, you could sort of like pass a SQL to another SQL command. And it was all driven through this Python library. And so that was fine.
它生成的SQL完全无法阅读，简直糟透了。所以我最后不得不重做我所有的工作，也就是手写那些SQL查询。后来我在很久之后去了另一家公司，又犯了完全相同的错误。他们当时有一个叫Data Swarm的工具。Data Swarm这个工具允许你编写一堆SQL，而且可以把它们写成代码块的形式。你可以编写一条SQL命令，然后不用去写那些变得非常丑陋的嵌套SQL命令，而是可以把一条SQL传递给另一条SQL命令。这一切都是通过一个Python库来驱动的。所以这倒也还好。
But then they have this thing called Data Swarm Studio, which was the same thing, drag and drop. You put little blocks of SQL in these boxes and you connect them with arrows and it knows to chain the commands together. And for both of these, I thought the tools were pretty nice. And so I used them and in both times, they killed them and then I ended up having to redo all the work. And both times, actually,
但后来他们推出了一个叫Data Swarm Studio的东西，原理是一样的，就是拖放。你把一小块一小块的SQL放进这些方框里，然后用箭头把它们连起来，它就知道把这些命令串联起来。对于这两款工具，我当时都觉得挺不错的，所以我用了它们。但两次它们都被下线了，结果我都不得不把所有工作重新做一遍。而且说实话，这两次的原因
the reasons were exactly the same. They said that it was just a nightmare for data engineers, other people. So basically it was easy for you to create something it was hard for someone else to you know build state on what you were doing so it's much easier for other people to just look at a page of code than to like look at all these boxes and arrows because you once you start introducing all of that now you have this like spatial model, spatial model. Yes. That like, like this, yeah, this model that has congruency between like your mind and how you think of
完全一模一样。他们说这简直是数据工程师和其他人的噩梦。所以基本上就是，你自己创建东西很容易，但对其他人来说，要搞清楚你到底在做什么的状态却很难。因此，其他人去看一页代码，要比去看一堆方框和箭头容易得多，因为一旦你开始引入所有这些东西，你就会引入一种空间模型、空间模型。对的。这种模型在你的大脑、你对事物的空间思考方式以及项目之间具有一致性。所以我想，你知道的，这对其他人来说真的很难。不同的人在空间布局上会有完全不同的方式。所以，是的，我从来没用过LabVIEW，但总的来说，我尽量远离所见即所得工具，因为尽管我觉得它很棒，但我已经被坑过太多次了。你让我想起了——这虽然是个题外话，我们该继续了——但那就是Zachtronics的游戏。比如《化工大亨》（Chem Factor）或者其他一些游戏，甚至像
things spatially and, and the project. And so I guess like, you know, that is something that's really hard for other people. Like, like different people come in with totally different ways of, you know, laying things out spatially. And so, yeah, I've never used lab view, but, but in general, I try and stay away from WYSIWYG because even though I think it's great, I've just been burned too many times. You're reminding me of this is a toilet side and we should move on, but that is it Zachtronics. So like chem factory or, you know, some of the other games, like even
《人力资源机器》（Human Resource Machine）之类的，看起来真的很简单，按照我的方式做就行了。然后如果你把你做展示给我看，要我坐下来真正去解析那些缺乏语法（就像我们为更高效的编程语言所设计的语法那样）的东西，其实会非常困难。是的。这可以说是理解别人所做工作的一种障碍。当你创建它时，它对你来说是有意义的，你可以看着它、理解它、追踪并调试它，但让其他人快速上手就没那么容易了。对的，对的，这说得通。嗯，詹姆斯·F（James F），你是我们的下一位获奖者。詹姆斯·F是一位全新的赞助人。
human resource machine or whatever, where like, it seems really simple and like how I do it. And then if you showed me what you did, like, it would be really hard for me to like sit down and actually parse out like the lack of syntax in the way that we do syntax for like more efficient programming languages. Yeah. It's sort of an impediment to like understanding what someone else did like it made sense when you created it and you can look at it and understand and track and debug it but bringing someone else up to speed is a bit more tricky yep yep that makes sense um so james f you are our next winner. James F is a brand new patron.
他已经支持了一个多月了。所以，詹姆斯，你现在是净赚了。你其实现在就可以取消订阅了。我开玩笑的。孩子们会受苦的，詹姆斯。他们会因为你而听不到这个节目了。不，我开玩笑的。不过詹姆斯是一位全新的赞助人，很幸运赢得了一件衬衣。
He's been on for over one month. So, so James, you are net positive. You can actually cancel your subscription now. I'm just kidding. And kids will suffer, James. They will not be able to hear about the show because of you. No, I'm just kidding. But James is a brand new patron, was lucky and won a shirt.
恭喜你，詹姆斯。我还得获取你的地址。系统里没有。不过说真的，非常感谢你成为我们的赞助人。我是说，我们刚才开玩笑呢。看到新朋友加入并注册真的太棒了。是的，我会找到你，
Congratulations, James. And I'll have to get your address. It's not in the system. But no, seriously, I mean, thanks so much for being a patron. I mean, we're just kidding. And it's really great to see new folks, you know, joining and signing up. And yeah, I will track you down
把T恤寄给你，詹姆斯。谢谢。好了，我们回答完了开始之前准备的问题，不过有些听众一直在和我们互动。我知道我找不到那个帖子了，但我想有人评论了关于
and get a t-shirt over to you, James. Thanks. So we got through the questions we had before we started, but some people have been interacting with us. I know I can't find the thread, but I think someone commented about
未来技术或重大技术的问题。AR怎么样？哦，AR怎么样？这很有意思。嗯，我可以这么说，我今年真的迷上了VR。我知道我们在过去的节目中讨论过，但我对大多数事情都是超级晚期才接受的。和智能手机类似，我是免费得到一个VR头显的，这大概是我拥有它的唯一原因。但后来我真的迷上它了。其实，我今天还用过它。
for future technology or big technologies. What about AR? Oh, what about AR? That's interesting. Well, I can say that I really got into VR this year. I know we talked about it on a past show, but I was a super late adopter to most things. Similar to a smartphone, I got a VR headset for free, which is probably the only reason why I have one. But then I really got into it. And actually, I was on it today. I
我是说，我现在就戴着它呢。我一周要用好多次。我非常喜欢用它来锻炼。我觉得锻炼加上VR，对我来说简直太合拍了。它真的让我很有感觉。不过，说到AR，我见过一些很酷的AR应用，但我不知道自己是否真的见过那种“杀手级应用”。我是说，我记得当年谷歌眼镜（Google Glass）刚出来的时候，那是个很酷的想法，但我记得没人真正用它做过什么。其实我特别想上手的一样东西是Snapchat的Spectacles眼镜，就是那种把摄像头内置在太阳镜镜框里的太阳镜。这样你就不用把手机拿出来拍照了。你知道的，我错过了太多精彩的照片，因为等你把手机掏出来、打开相机应用时，那个时刻已经
mean, I'm on it right now. I'm on it multiple times a week. I'm really into doing exercise. I feel like exercise plus VR, for me, it just works really well. It just really clicks for me. But yeah, so AR, I've seen some cool things with AR, but I don't know if I've really seen that killer app. I mean, I remember when Google Glass came out, it was a cool idea, but no one really did anything. One thing I would love to get my hands on actually is the Snapchat spectacles, where it's like those, those sunglasses that have cameras built into the sunglasses. So you don't have to take your phone out to take a picture. You know, I like I miss so many great photos, because by the time you take your phone out, go to the camera, it's like the moment's
过去了。所以我觉得，那些真的挺酷的，但我还没看到一个真正的AR杀手级应用。帕特里克，你觉得呢？我觉得AR——我之前跟某人讨论过这个——是那种迟早会实现的技术，我们终究会拥有它。但问题在于，我们现在是否有合适的技术状态来实现它？我不知道这是否总是成立，因为就像飞行汽车一样——在我们意识到“是的，它们大概不会成为现实”之前，人们总觉得它们迟早会实现——但我感觉AR是如此明显，在某种形式上是如此显然，以至于总有一天会有人摸索出正确的模式：比如要实现真正流畅的体验需要什么？如何针对你的感知进行调整？如何把延迟降得足够低？如何做出一个杀手级应用？我感觉它实在是太实用了，如果以极低的边际成本把它加到我现有的眼镜或太阳镜里，
gone, you know. So that I think um you know those i think are really cool but i have yet to see an ar you know killer app i mean what do you feel patrick i think ar is i was having this conversation with someone is one of those things that will come we will eventually get it but the question is like do we have the right technology at the right state to do it now i don't know that that's always true because like flying cars never like we're always going to be a thing until we realized yeah they probably won't be a thing um but i feel like ar is just so like in some form is so obvious eventually someone will work out the pattern like what's needed to just do it real slick like adjusting for your what you're perceiving getting the latency low enough like having a killer app like i feel like it's just too useful that like if it were you know super low marginal cost to just add
你为什么不这么做呢？哪怕它的功能很基础，只要价格够低。是的。其实有两款AR应用是我最近开始关注并体验的，我觉得非常酷。其中一个是，你见过Brickit吗？我想我们在节目里讨论过。Brickit这个应用是这样的：你把一堆随机的乐高积木铺在你的地毯上，确保没有任何遮挡。你把它们铺在地毯上，然后用Brickit应用拍张照片，它就会分析所有的积木，弄清楚它们是什么，然后告诉你一个你可以搭建的、很酷的东西。它甚至会给你提供分步的说明以及所有相关指导。对的，你提起过，我得去试试看。
it to my existing glasses or to sunglasses like why would you not do it? Even if it was low functionality, if the, if the price were low enough. Yeah. There's actually, there's two AR things that I started, uh, that I checked out, which I thought were really cool. One was that, have you seen Brickit? I think we talked about it on the show. Brickit is this thing where you, you take a whole bunch of random Lego pieces, you lay them out on your carpet, you make sure that there's no occlusions. You lay them out on your carpet and then you take a picture with the BrickIt app and it will actually, you know, analyze all the pieces, figure out what they are, and then tell you something cool you can build. And it'll actually give you the instructions step-by-step and everything. Yeah, you did tell, I'm going to have to try this.
经你这么一说，我现在又兴奋起来了。我正打算现在就打开手机呢。我以前从没试过。但我觉得这算是一个真正的AR突破。另外我最近发现的一件事是——我不确定这东西效果到底有多好——有一整类围绕
Like you told me about it again. Now I'm like excited. I'm like going on my phone right now. I've never tried it. But so that I think is an AR real breakthrough. And then another thing that I found out recently is, and I'm not sure how well this works, but there's a whole collection of apps around
生产力（我猜是吧）的应用程序。我看到过这样一个应用：你给地上的一堆东西拍张照片。在这个应用里，其实是允许有遮挡之类的东西存在的。唯一的规则是所有的东西必须是同一种物品。你拍下一堆东西的照片，它就会告诉你大约有多少个。所以，比如你撒了一堆东西在地上，它会告诉你大概的数量。再比如，你把一堆钉子撒在地板上，拍张照片，它就会说：“哦，47颗钉子。”而且它的结果可能非常准确，误差在一两颗钉子以内。这真是一个很酷的应用。
productivity, I guess. So there's one app I saw where you take a picture of a collection of stuff on the ground. And in this app, there actually can be occlusions and stuff. The only rule is that all the things have to be the same. You take a picture of a pile of things and it will tell you approximately how many there are. So, you know, you drop a bunch of things and it will tell you approximately how many there are. So, you know, you drop a bunch of nails on the floor, you take a picture. It's like, oh, 47 nails. And it might be right, like within one or two nails. That's a really cool app.
还有另一个应用，基本上就像一把直尺或者卷尺。是的，它利用了AR。对的，我觉得这类应用真的非常非常酷。事实上，我觉得甚至谷歌眼镜现在也还在被医生使用，还有其他一些生产力方面的用途让它延续到了今天。好的，下一个话题是关于是否应该攻读硕士学位或上课，你觉得获得认证证书（Certificates）有什么好处吗？帕特里克，你有什么看法？我会这么说，这因人而异，差距巨大。我跟一些人聊过，他们说在他们公司，这就像是一个
And there's another app that's effectively like a ruler or like a tape measure. Yeah. It uses AR. Yeah. I think these kind of things are really, really cool. And actually, I think even Google Class, I think it's still used, right, by doctors and there's a couple of other productivity uses that it's kept it alive today. Yeah, so the next one was on the topic of getting a master's degree or classes, do you see a benefit of getting certifications um what's your take patrick so i will say this varies hugely i know i've talked to people that say like at their work like it is a
硬性标准：你必须拥有一定数量的（他们这里举了例子，比如AWS、Scrum Master头衔）各种证书，甚至还有各种IT证书。所以我跟一些人聊过，他们必须完成一定数量的培训课程并获得这些证书才能获得晋升。如果情况确实如此，那当然没问题，你必须得去考。那些地方如果你带着证书去应聘，可能也会得到认可。但说实话，在我现在的地方，这根本无所谓。如果你的简历上有这些证书，你来面试，我也不会知道它们是什么。其他人也不会知道它们是什么。我们根本不知道哪些证书容易考，哪些难考。所以我也不能
rubric like you must have x number of you know they they give examples here like aws scrum master titles like these various certificates, or even there's all the IT certificates. So I talked to people who like you must have x amount of training classes and these things to like get a promotion. Or if you don't like if that's the case, like, yeah, sure got to do it. And those places probably would respect it if you came in. But look, I'll tell you honestly, where I am, it doesn't matter a lick. Like if you have it on your resume, and you show up, I'm not going to know what they are. No one else is going to know what they are. We're not going to know which ones are easy or hard to get. So I won't
说它们毫无意义，因为你可能会遇到懂行的人。但我知道有些证书很容易拿，只需要花时间就行；我也知道有些证书确实非常硬核、很难考下来，但我分不清两者的区别。所以要我对它们做出评估挺困难的。因此，这些并不是我会寻找的东西，我也不会鼓励那些想要在我公司找工作的人去追求这些证书。是的，这说得通。不过我要从一个稍微更乐观的角度来看待这个问题。我认为，如果我看到一份证书，它向我展示的是这个人对某个领域有兴趣。我可能无法了解得足够透彻去判断这个证书是否严格（比如它是否要求很高、是否全面、是否具备权威认证）。但至少，举个例子，某个人的学位可能是机械工程。
say like they're meaningless, because you could find someone who knew what they meant. But I know that some certifications are easy, you just put in the time. I know that some are really hard to actually legit, like difficult to get, but I don't know the difference. And so it's a bit hard for me to make an assessment of them. So they don't, they're not something I look for or would encourage people trying to get a job at my workplace to pursue. Yeah, that makes sense. I would say, I would take a little bit more optimistic point of view. I think that if I see a certificate, what it shows to me is that the person has an interest in an area. I can't really know enough to say, is this certificate, you know, did it require, you know, like how challenging it is or how comprehensive it is or how accredited it is. But at least, so for example, someone might have a degree in mechanical engineering.
你可能会立刻纳闷：“为什么这个人要加入某个AI研究实验室，而他却是个机械工程学位？”如果简历上写着“哦，我知道，我在几年前拿到了那个学位”，这可能有点说不通。但如果简历上写着“一年前，我在Coursera上修了这门关于深度学习或类似主题的课程”，这就表明：“哦，这个人想要转型，而且他正在投入时间和精力去学习一套不同的技能。”这就至少传递了一个信号，而这个信号可能对
And you might think right off the bat, like, why is this person joining some AI research lab and they have a degree in mechanical engineering? And so it might not really make sense if they say, oh, but, you know, I got if the resume says, oh, yeah, I got that degree, let's say years ago. But a year ago, I took this Coursera course on, you know, deep learning or something like that. And it shows like, OK, this person, you know, wants to pivot and, you know, they're putting time and effort into learning, you know, a different set of skills. And so that at least like sends a message and that message might be important to, um, to get the interview. Um, now like, you know, you're, you're, I don't think anyone's going to trust any of those certificates. So you're still, you know, you know, the best case is you get the interview and you're
获得面试机会至关重要。当然了，没人会盲目相信那些证书。所以到头来，最好的情况是你获得了面试机会，接下来你就会在AI理论方面接受测试，懂就是懂，不懂就是不懂。我不认为会有人说：“哦，好吧，我不必面试这个人了，因为他有证书，对吧？”但是，是的，我想说，这可能有助于通过招聘源头和面试的早期筛选阶段。至于你是否真的能学到正确的材料以及所有相关的知识，这里面的变数太多了，很难有一个确切的答案。是的，我想这就是关键所在——任何东西都可以是附加值，问题在于：跟什么相比？如果你把时间花在这个上面，而不是用来提交一个开源项目或者做点别的什么事情，对吧？这就是你需要去权衡的。因此，这归根结底取决于你的学习风格、你的动力、你的
going to get tested on AI theory and you're going to know it or not. I don't think anyone's going to say, oh, well, I don't have to interview this person. They have a certificate, right? But yeah, I would say, you know, it probably is good to get, you know, get past the sourcing and the, you know, early stages of screening of an interview. And yeah, as far as like, will you actually learn the right material and everything that it's just there's too much variance to really know the answer there yeah i guess like that's the thing like anything can be a value add the question is like relative to what like if you're doing that instead of spending time committing to an open source project or doing something else right like that's what you got to ask and for then it's a question of like your style of learning, your motivations, your
技能组合以及你所追求的工作。这里面的变量实在是太多了。这确实是个很好的观点。你知道的，如果我看到——顺着我的例子继续说——如果我看到一份简历，上面列出了一些GitHub项目，或者他们参与了某些AI相关的群组，比如某个LinkedIn上的AI群组，甚至如果他们在管理这样的群组，我认为我能从中获得同样的信号，
skill sets, the job you're going after. Like there's just too many variables. That's a really good point, actually. You know, if I saw, you know, to continue my example, if I saw a resume where someone pointed out some GitHub projects or if they were involved in like some groups on, you know, AI, like maybe some LinkedIn group on AI, if they were involved in like some groups on AI, like maybe some LinkedIn group on AI, if they were moderating that, I think I could get the same signal
足以直接开启一场面试，而不需要这个人去拿整个学位。我觉得，还有其他一些——抱歉，还有一个。然后人们在评论我们已经讨论过的事情，但这就像是一个无休止的循环。所以我可能得在这里打住。不过，要想成为一名开发人员有多难？我想，我们在节目里可能提过也可能没提过，但我觉得小型公司绝对是首选。你知道的，
and like enough to kick off an interview without the person having to get this whole degree. I think that, so I think there's some other, oh, sorry, one more. And then people commenting about things we already commented on, but this is a never ending loop. So I'll have to probably cut it there. But how hard would it be to get a job developer. I think, you know, I think we, I don't know if I mentioned this on the show or not, but I think, you know, smaller companies are definitely the way to go. You know,
这里存在一种观点，关于你的“简历实力”与你的“面试实力”。当你的面试实力比简历实力高得多、强得多时，你在小型公司往往能做得非常好。因为小型公司会——嗯，也许不是筛选每一位候选人，但它们至少会查看每一份简历。它们甚至可能会给每一个投递简历的人打电话。所以绝对地，这是建立你简历的好方法。一旦你有了——当你有了5年经验，尤其是到了有10年经验的时候，我觉得基本上没人会再去看你毕业于哪所大学了。所以关键在于如何让飞轮转起来。
there's this idea of sort of, you know, your resume strength versus your interview strength. And when your interview strength is a lot higher, a lot stronger than your resume strength, then you'll tend to do really well at smaller companies. And because smaller companies will, you know, will screen every, well, maybe not screen every candidate, but they'll at least look at every single resume. And they might even call every single person who applies. And so definitely, that's a good way to build up your resume. Once you, you know, once you have, you you have five, definitely by the time you have 10 years of experience, I don't think anyone's really looking at your college anymore. And so it's really just about how do you get the flywheel turning?
因此，我认为小型公司是实现这一目标的绝佳途径。许多大公司会收到数百万份简历，他们有各种各样的自动化筛选系统。就像谷歌那部电影《实习大叔》（The Internship）里的那个笑话。有个情节是，主角正试图找人加入他的实习生团队，他问对方是在哪所大学上的学。对方回答说：“某某大学（University of）……”结果还没等对方说完，仅仅因为校名是以“University of”开头，那家伙就说：“下一个，我知道了，我对你没兴趣了。”所以，电影里的那个桥段总是让我觉得很烦躁，但不管怎样，我的意思是，
And so I think small companies are a good way to do that. A lot of the bigger companies, they get millions of resumes and they have all sorts of automatic screening. There's that joke from the Google movie, The Internship. There's this joke where the person is trying to find people to join his intern group. And he asks where the person went to college. The person says University of. And then before he can even say it, just because it started with University of the guy's like next, you know, I'm done with you. And so, and so, uh, that part of the movie always annoyed me, but, but anyway, I mean, the point there is, uh, is that, you know,
他们要经历如此多的面试，以至于他们完全是在为了100%的准确率而进行优化，对吧？如果他们错失了100个优秀候选人中的99个也没关系，只要他们能招到足够填满团队的优秀候选人就行，对吧？所以，是的，从小型公司开始吧。是的，其实这里还有一个大问题：你是否应该回头去拿一个本科学位？这是一个非常难回答的问题。我觉得这取决于很多很多因素。但如果你只有副学士学位（Associate's degree）又想开始工作，那就从小型公司做起，积累简历，然后一往直前，不用回头看。我觉得你会没事的。是的。我觉得这是一个相当全面的
they go through so many interviews that they are optimizing for, um, um, they're optimizing for a hundred percent for precision, right? And if they lose 99 out of 100 good candidates, that's fine as long as they get enough good candidates to fill up their teams, right? So yeah, start with a smaller company. Yeah, I mean, there's a whole question around should you go back and get a bachelor's degree? I mean, that's a very hard question. I think it depends on many, many factors. But if you have an associates and you want to start working, you know, start with a smaller company, build up that resume and, and don't really ever look back. I think you'll be fine. Yeah. I think that was a pretty comprehensive
回答了。这确实取决于具体情况，但我想再次从宏观角度补充一点：如果换个角度不直接回答，而是从相对的角度来看，拥有副学士学位想要找到第一份工作，确实比拥有本科学位要困难得多。而且我要说的是，这相当困难，你会发现拥有副学士学位的人——哪怕带有一些工作经验——能成功入行的比例要远低于拥有本科学位的人。部分原因在于——这可能是一种误解，但部分原因在于——大多数副学士学位并没有涵盖你在本科学位中所学的那种特定专业课程。
answer. Like it, it really depends, but I would say again, like on the scale, if I took it on to take a different tack rather than answering it, absolutely answering it relatively, which is, it is much harder to get that first job with an associates than a bachelor's degree. And, and I would say it's like a pretty, pretty hard, like it's, it's, it's, it would be significantly hard, you'd find a lot fewer people getting in with associates, even with some work experience than people with bachelor's degrees. And I think in part, and that may be like a misunderstanding, but in part, most associates degrees don't cover the like degree specific stuff that you get into in a bachelor's degree.
据我所知，大多数情况下，当你获得副学士学位时，它不会涵盖大量的计算机科学课程或更高级别的领域特定内容。你是在每个阶段不断提炼和深造的，对吧？你在本科学位中添加它，在硕士学位中精炼它，在博士学位中将其推向极致。
So at least as far as I'm aware, most of the time when you get an associate's degree, it's not going to cover a ton of computer science courses or higher level, like domain specific stuff, just like you get that refinement at each level, right? You add it in your bachelor's, you refine it in your master's, you even further in your PhD.
所以我想，就像Jason所说的那样，必须有其他证据或某种叙事来解释这一切。是的，完全说得通。那我们再聊最后一个，然后就差不多收尾了。来自宾夕法尼亚州的唐（Don），他成为会员已经快四年了——哇，真是好久啊。
And so I guess there would have to be like Jason is saying, there would have to be other evidence or is saying there would have to be other evidence or some narrative that explained like what that was yep yep totally makes sense so we'll do one more and then we'll kind of close it out so don r from pennsylvania who um who's been a member for almost four years so wow what a long What a long time. I mean, it's, uh, that's incredible. I didn't realize we've been on Patreon that long, but, uh, man, time really does fly, doesn't it? Um, so yeah, Don, um, you know, thank you so much for your support. We'll be sending you over a t-shirt. I got your address. So we'll, um,
真是太久了。我是说，这太不可思议了。我没意识到我们在Patreon上已经待了这么久，但是，天哪，时间真的过得飞快，不是吗？所以，是的，唐，非常感谢你的支持。我们会给你寄一件T恤。我已经拿到你的地址了。所以我们会，
we'll definitely get you a t-shirt and um yeah thanks all our patreons just a bit of a sort of meta stuff here last time we did this um two people of the five winners um i knew personally and so i kind of felt a little bad it was it was like and it was just random um you know it know, it's, it was very low probability of that happening, but it did. Um, and I'm looking at it right now and almost all of my personal friends are at the bottom. So that's just how the cookie crumbled this year. But in a way it makes me feel good that, uh, you have, uh, uh, some, some brand new folks here getting, uh, getting prizes, which is, which is really, really awesome.
我们肯定会给你寄一件T恤的。谢谢所有的赞助人！这里还有个有趣的小插曲：上一次我们抽奖时，五位获奖者中有两位是我个人的朋友，所以我当时觉得有点不好意思。这纯粹是随机的，这种情况发生的概率非常低，但它确实发生了。而我现在看了一下名单，我几乎所有的个人朋友都排在最底下了。所以这就是今年命运的安排。但从某种程度上说，这让我感到很欣慰，因为今年有一些全新的朋友赢得了奖品，这真的是非常非常棒的事情。
And thank you everybody for your support and all of your contributions. We really appreciate it. So maybe we'll go out on, conclude on a kind of question. Like what is your, I think we talked about tech trends. I think last year you were saying how space is going to be a big deal,
非常感谢大家的每一份支持和贡献。我们真的非常感激。所以，也许我们可以以一个问题来作为总结。比如，你觉得——我们之前讨论了科技趋势。我想去年你说过太空将成为一个大事件，
or was that something we did in the middle of the year? I talk about it all the time. Well, I feel like space in 2021 didn't get that much attention, but I think that's because all of the other crazy things that happened in the world really took precedent. I mean, with the pandemic and everything. But I mean, I have video of sitting with my my kids and watching them blow up several starships and then finally land one on my phone as we live streamed it in my living room. Was that this year? Yeah. Oh, man.
还是说那是我们在年中时讨论的？我一直在谈论这个。嗯，我觉得太空在2021年并没有受到那么多关注，但我想那是因为世界上发生的其他那些疯狂的事情真正占据了主导地位，我是指疫情以及所有这些事情。不过，我确实有自己和孩子们坐在一起的视频，看着他们炸毁了几艘星舰（Starship），最后在客厅里看直播时，终于成功在我的手机上看到一艘星舰成功着陆。那是今年吗？是的。哦，天哪。
OK. Yeah. I'm out of the loop. So actually, 2021 has been long geez yeah so so your prediction was that i think your prediction was that in 2021 they would kind of figure out basically what you just said so i think you got it spot on oh oh wow okay i think my prediction was around education, if I remember correctly. I said that I don't know if we I don't think we made one year predictions, but we were just making predictions about the future. And I was predicting that that there'd be a lot more sort of privatized education and scholarships. And actually, you know, one thing that kind of, you know, is starting to corroborate this is, you know, there was a big push to cancel the student debt, which I think would have really just kept the system going, right? But then now it seems like that's not happening.
好吧。我有点落伍了。所以其实2021年真的很长，天哪。所以你的预测是——我想你的预测是，在2021年他们会基本上搞定你刚才所说的事情，所以我觉得你完全预测对了。哦，哇，好吧。我记得我的预测是关于教育的，如果我没记错的话。我说过，我不确定我们是否做过一年期的预测，但我们当时只是在对未来进行预测。我预测未来会有更多私有化的教育和奖学金。事实上，你知道的，有一件事开始佐证这一点，那就是当时有一股很大的呼吁取消学生贷款的浪潮，我觉得这其实只会让原有的体制继续运转下去，对吧？但现在看来这似乎并没有发生。
And so, yeah, I'm going to stick to that idea. And I think that scholarships and a lesser degree, you know, academia in general is going to become kind of more privatized and maybe more decentralized. So we'll see. It's been such a crazy year. It's hard to really make progress in that kind of area. But I still think I'm still going to hold on to that prediction. I think it's going to happen. What is your prediction for space? I mean, yeah. I was dead air because i was trying to think of something impact was like the vacuum of spit no i'm just kidding um wasn't there there was a probe that like went to the surface of the sun or something just yeah
所以，是的，我将坚持这个观点。我认为奖学金以及在较小程度上整个学术界，将变得更加私有化，也许会更加去中心化。我们拭目以待吧。今年实在是太疯狂了，很难真正在那种领域取得太大进展。但我仍然坚持这个预测。我认为它会发生。你对太空领域的预测是什么？我是说，是的。刚才冷场了，因为我在绞尽脑汁想要想出一个有影响力的东西，就像是真空中的口水——不，我开玩笑的。难道不是有个探测器去了太阳表面或者别的什么地方吗？是的，就在最近。
there was yeah just recently i mean i think my prediction for space and technology is going to be like you're going to see a huge rollout with Starlink because they continue to just push almost 100 satellites. I think it's like 70 satellites or something per launch. And so they're just putting so many satellites up. I think you're going to see a huge rollout of Starlink this year and continue to see all the other companies flap around. I think the James Webb Teles telescope is going to make it up and deploy successfully, finally, this next year.
我是说，我对太空和技术的预测是，你会看到Starlink（星链）的大规模铺开，因为他们一直在不断发射卫星，几乎每次发射都有近100颗卫星。我记得每次发射大约是70颗左右的卫星。所以他们正在把如此多的卫星送入太空。我认为你今年会看到Starlink的大规模部署，并且会继续看到其他公司手忙脚乱。我认为詹姆斯·韦伯太空望远镜（James Webb Telescope）今年将成功升空并顺利展开。
And that's not SpaceX related. And I think we'll see Starship do at least two orbital tests where they successfully do orbits. Cool. Yeah, actually, you just reminded me that uh yeah william shatner and a bunch of these celebrities went to space origin yeah yeah right actually it's a beer for space we should do you know we should definitely do a space episode i mean you you know you'll do the talking i'll ask a bunch of dumb questions but but we should definitely definitely do a space episode what about you know i've heard about like there's there's too much debris like where the satellites are is that a real thing or is that just fear and um i mean it is a real thing and people say oh if it gets bad
而且这与SpaceX无关。我认为我们会看到星舰（Starship）进行至少两次成功的轨道测试飞行。酷。是的，你刚才提醒了我，威廉·夏特纳（William Shatner）和一帮名人去了太空——还有蓝色起源（Blue Origin）什么的。是的，没错。其实，这简直是为太空干杯。我们应该搞一期——我们绝对应该做一期关于太空的节目。我是说，你来主讲，我来问一堆蠢问题，但我们绝对应该做一期太空主题的节目。关于——我听说太空中有太多太空碎片了，卫星所在的轨道真的很危险吗？这是一种真实存在的威胁，还是只是杞人忧天？
enough like we won't be able to go to space anymore like we'll lose access to space. I think that's a bit of a stretch because we know how we could at great expense, you know, sort of fix the problem, which is basically stuff starts colliding with itself in outer space. And you just form this cloud of debris, this shell of debris that just, you know, hovers around the earth. And so getting in and out of orbit is harder um i think it wouldn't happen right away if we know how to clean it up if we needed to i think it's one of those things that it's just like the first people to land in a new uh unexplored island or whatever can say like oh i'm gonna harvest these giant you know trees for my ship masks and then the next people who come you know like each as it becomes more and more subtle you have to be more and more
我是说，这确实是真实存在的威胁。人们会说，如果情况变得足够糟糕，我们将无法再进入太空，我们将失去进入太空的通道。我觉得这有点夸大其词了，因为我们知道，如果付出巨大代价，我们其实有办法解决这个问题——也就是太空中开始发生碰撞，从而形成一团碎片云，一层刚好悬浮在地球周围的碎片外壳。因此，进出轨道会变得更加困难。
conscientious about preserving what's there and you can pillage it but you can also realize hey this is not sustainable and you can you know adapt it which mitigates the situation from spiraling out of control. And then you enact some ability to clean those things up. So I think we'll see as it gets cheaper and cheaper to get to space, you'll get more stuff in space, but you'll also have the ability to go, you know, deorbit things which could otherwise cause more space debris. Makes sense. I guess a couple of facts just to end this on, which I think, you know,
我觉得如果我们需要清理的话，这种事不会立刻发生，因为我们知道该怎么做。这就像第一批登上某个全新未探索岛屿的人可能会说：“哦，我要砍伐这些巨树来做我的船桅”，而随后到来的人会发现——随着情况变得越来越微妙，你必须越来越有意识地去保护现有的东西。你可以去掠夺它，但你也会意识到“嘿，这不可持续”，然后你就可以去调整它，从而避免局势失控。随后，你就会制定出清理这些东西的能力。所以我想，随着进入太空的成本越来越低，太空中的东西会越来越多，但我们也将具备让物体脱离轨道的能力，从而防止它们产生更多的太空碎片。有道理。我想最后以几个事实来结束今天的节目。我觉得，
really, you know, it's been a very tough year. We kind of started the show by talking about what a difficult year it is. But a couple of amazing facts I saw. One is the earth has 30% more trees than it did at the start of the Industrial Revolution. And it has something like, I think America has something like 30% more trees than it did 15 years ago. Something like that. It's just unbelievable.
今年真的是非常艰难的一年。我们在节目开头讨论过今年是多么艰难的一年。但我看到了一些令人惊叹的事实。其中一个事实是：地球上的树木数量比工业革命开始时增加了30%。而且有类似的数据表明，美国的树木数量比15年前增加了大约30%。大概就是这样。这简直令人难以置信。
The amount of reforestation is unbelievable. And another really cool fact is global poverty over the past 100 years went from 57% to I think it's just seven or maybe it's 52 to seven. But I mean, it's enormous, like decrease in global poverty. And so, you know, things are actually like, you know, overall, things are amazing. I mean, you put on a long enough horizon, you start looking like 30, 40 years, and there's
植树造林的规模简直不可思议。另一个非常酷的事实是，在过去100年里，全球贫困率从57%下降到了——我想现在大概只有7%，或者可能是从52%下降到7%。但我的意思是，全球贫困率出现了巨幅下降。所以，事情其实是——总的来说，情况非常棒。如果你把眼光放得足够长远，开始观察30年、40年的周期，你就会发现
been amazing, remarkable progress that, you know, the whole world should be super proud of. So in that sense, it's been pretty awesome. But of course, you need to get the pandemic figured out. Cool. All right. I think we can wrap it up there. You know, it's been a really amazing year. I know Patrick and I both moved, so it's been a very, very busy year. Actually, I moved last year, but I'm still recovering. It's been a very busy year for both of us, but I hope it's been a great year able to have your ears for an hour every month or every two weeks now that we have a producer.
取得了惊人的、了不起的进步，全世界都应该为此感到无比自豪。从这个意义上说，今年其实挺棒的。当然了，你还得先把疫情彻底搞定。酷。好的，我想我们可以在这里收尾了。这是一个非常了不起的一年。我知道帕特里克和我今年都搬家了，所以这是非常非常忙碌的一年。其实我是去年搬的，但我现在还在恢复元气。对我们俩来说，这都是忙碌的一年。但我希望今年对大家来说也是棒极的一年，能够每个月或者每两周（现在我们有了制作人）抽出一个小时来听我们的节目。
And we want to keep the show going. We will keep the show going. We have a bunch of cool interviews lined up. We have a bunch of cool topics lined up. We have space. We have space topic lined up. I'm ready. All right, cool.
我们想要把这个节目继续办下去。我们会继续办下去的。我们安排了一系列很酷的采访，也策划了一系列很酷的话题。我们有太空。我们安排了太空的主题。我已经准备好了。好的，酷。
And yeah, thanks everyone again for supporting this show. And we'll see you all next year. See ya. Music by Eric Barndollar. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再次感谢大家对本期节目的支持。我们明年再见。拜拜。片尾曲由Eric Barndollar制作。《编程抛弃》（Programming Throwdown）在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0协议（Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license）下发布。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输本作品，也可以进行混音和改编，但您必须对帕特里克和我进行署名，并以相同的条款分享。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。